Tim Ferriss: Arthur, so nice to have you here.
Thanks for joining.
Arthur Brooks: Thank you, Tim.
It's great to be with you.
I've been looking forward to this.
Tim Ferriss: Me too.
Arthur Brooks: I feel like we've been looking
forward to meeting and we've been warming
up for this for a long time.
Tim Ferriss: We have.
Arthur Brooks: We have so many friends in
common.
Tim Ferriss: We have a lot of friends in common.
I have read your prior work, From Strength
to Strength, excellent book recommended to
me by Peter Attia.
People may know him as Dr. Peter Attia, good
friend, proud Texan also now.
Arthur Brooks: Where all the cool kids live,
we're all of Texas.
Tim Ferriss: Where all the cool kids are.
And I have more questions than we will have
time, but I'm hoping to really explore broadly,
and I wanted to start with something that
I thought would pique the interest of many
people listening, and that is the reverse
bucket list.
Is this something you still do and what does
it entail?
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, the reverse bucket list
is something I do.
Oh, boy, do I ever do it and it took me too
long to figure this one out.
When I was 50, I'm 59 years old.
When I was 50, I found my bucket list from
when I was 40.
It was a classic thing, and on my birthday,
I would make a list of my desires and my ambitions,
and I would imagine myself, visualize myself
consuming or experiencing these things and
it would fire me up and make me well feel
like a loser, quite frankly, because it was
lowering my sense of satisfaction I subsequently
found out.
I looked at that list from when I was 40,
and I checked everything off that list and
I was less happy —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, no.
Arthur Brooks: — at 50 than I was at 40.
And so I thought, I'm a social scientist so
I thought to myself, obviously I'm doing something
wrong.
What am I doing wrong?
And basically this is the problem.
This is a neurophysiological problem and a
psychological problem all rolled into one
handy package.
I was making the mistake of thinking that
my satisfaction would come by having more.
And the truth of the matter is that lasting
and stable satisfaction, which doesn't wear
off in a minute, comes when you understand
that your satisfaction is your haves divided
by your wants.
Haves divided by wants.
That's the model.
So it's like I'll slow down because I know
people watching are like, "I'm going to write
that down."
Haves divided by wants.
You can increase your satisfaction temporarily
and inefficiently by having more, or permanently
and securely by wanting less.
I thought to myself, so what does that mean?
And the answer to that, what does that mean?
Is I need a reverse bucket list.
Not that I'm not going to get nice things
in my life, but I'm going to be consciously
detached from them by going through the exercise
of writing them down and crossing them out.
So on my birthday now, and my 59th birthday
a couple of months ago, I wrote down all my
ridiculous ambitions and desires of money
or whatever, power, ambition, admiration,
all these things that I want from other people
that we all want because we're human and Mother
Nature wires us to accumulate the rewards
that'll help us survive and pass our genes,
I got it.
I know how evolutionary psychology works,
and I know that these things are going to
occur to me as natural goals, but I do not
want to be owned by them.
I want to manage them.
I don't want them to be like phantasms in
my limbic system managing me.
I want to move the experience of these ambitions
to my prefrontal cortex, which is my executive
manager, the bumper of tissue right behind
my forehead.
And the way that you do that is by looking
at each one of these ambitions and saying,
"Maybe I get it and maybe I don't, but I'm
going to cross it out as an attachment."
And I'm telling you, Tim, I'm free.
Tim Ferriss: And so you find that to work.
Arthur Brooks: Oh, it works.
It does, not because you don't care about
it, but because you're not attached to it
in the same way.
You've made the decision to have it not be
a rootless desire, a ghost in your head.
You've made it into something that you will
consciously manage by literally experiencing
that ambition in a different part of your
brain.
Tim Ferriss: So you go through this exercise,
so you write down whatever it is, receive
such and such an honor, sell so many copies
of book X, whatever these are.
Arthur Brooks: All the stuff that guys like
you and me do.
Tim Ferriss: And then you have 37-inch arms
in your case possibly.
You're incredibly fit.
I'm not hitting on you, I'm just saying I
aspire to —
Arthur Brooks: You're a beautiful man too.
Tim Ferriss: Well, we go to the same stylist
for our haircuts, but I would say we will
maybe get to self-care and physical practice
later.
You go through this exercise, you write those
things down, you cross them out in an idol
worship, sleight-of-hand move.
Arthur Brooks: Right.
Tim Ferriss: And then following that, I'm
curious when is if there is the spark of this
desire, whatever it might be, do you have
self-talk or something that acts as an interrupt?
Arthur Brooks: I keep the list.
Tim Ferriss: You keep the list.
Arthur Brooks: I keep the list and I go back
and I look at the list just like I would look
at my bucket list later every six months or
every year, every 10 years, whatever it happened
to be.
I go back and look at my reverse bucket list
and say, "Am I living up to this?
Am I truly conscious?"
Tim Ferriss: "Am I living up to not being
attached?"
Arthur Brooks: "Am I practicing the detachment
that I committed myself to?"
And the truth is usually, yeah, kind of.
I mean, the phantasm will be back.
It will be flying around in your head again,
but you brought it to your prefrontal cortex
for a reason and your prefrontal cortex is
an adult and will govern the children.
But sometimes you have to remind yourself,
"Remember, look, I mean you're an adult here,"
and you look back on it and you say, and it's
funny.
Actually, it's pretty amusing when you look
at it and you say, "Oh, I can't believe that
thing is bugging me again."
But you're not governed by it in the same
way.
You know what I actually put on my list?
I was reading.
Tim Ferriss: Just for clarity, so it's okay
to have the goal and to have it as a target
and plan for it.
Let's say selling X number of copies, but
not to have that hungry ghost attachment to
it.
Arthur Brooks: It's nothing more than an intention.
Intention is fine, but attachment is bad.
And this is what the Dalai Lama talks about
too.
He talks about intention without attachment.
There's a word in sailing, the rhumb line.
In Spanish, rumbo, which is a lot more common
in normal everyday speech.
And what it means is it's the intention of
your voyage.
You have to have that even though you're not
going to be true to it, because if you don't
know you're just going to be going in circles,
you'll just be, "I don't know, I've been out
to sea for a long time.
Who knows where I am?"
It'll be like one of your vacations.
It's like, "I don't know where I am, I'm just
doing nothing, man," which is, it can be therapeutically
important, but it's actually not the way that
you get from Europe to the Americas.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Arthur Brooks: You need a rhumb line.
Tim Ferriss: You need a location and your
end point on the GPS.
Arthur Brooks: But if you're super attached
to it, then you're going to freak out when
something throws you off.
And furthermore, you're not going to recognize
the fact that it is the voyage itself that
is the adventure of life, not actually reaching
the particular destination, whether it's the
original one or one that turns out to be better
or worse or wherever you wind up.
And that's the way you've got to live your
life.
So it's intention without attachment.
Now there's another thing that I was thinking
about this year because Thích Nhất Hạnh
died, you know —
Tim Ferriss: I do.
Arthur Brooks: The great Vietnamese Buddhist
monk, and I wrote his obituary in The Washington
Post actually.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Arthur Brooks: It was a really interesting
experience.
I talked about all what he's taught all of
us.
And Thích Nhất Hạnh said, and I almost
had an impact on my, but I reflected on it
upon his death that one of the greatest attachments
that people have in modern life is to their
views and opinions.
That's a real attachment.
It can be as dangerous as your attachment
to money or power.
Why?
Because people treat their opinions as if
they were gold, they're jewels.
"Get between me and my political opinions,
man, I'll cancel you.
I'll get you fired.
I'll denounce you on social media.
Who knows, maybe I'll be violent."
I mean, life is crazy these days.
And so I looked at it and I thought, am I
weighed down by attachment to my views, to
my political views?
So I wrote down five of my strongest political
views and I crossed them out.
Tim Ferriss: This was after writing the obituary?
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, it was on my reverse
bucket list when I turned 59.
And I said, "Look, it's not that I don't have
these views, I just don't have the attachment
to these views.
Look, man, I need more friends, and strong
political opinions is not going to get me
there.
It's not going to get me there.
Love is going to get me there, tolerance is
going to get me there.
A sense of curiosity about other people is
going to get me there, and strong political
opinions is going to put me in the wrong direction."
So, man, dead.
The attachment, dead.
Tim Ferriss: So maybe this is a little too
granular, but I'm curious.
Thích Nhất Hạnh, this is a legendary
figure.
I would be very intimidated by the task of
writing an obituary for such a person.
I've read numbers of his books, been very
influenced by his thinking.
How do you go about deciding what goes into
an obituary for someone like that, or for
anyone for that matter, but in this particular
case?
Arthur Brooks: The Germans talk about doing
something called a festschrift.
It's a word that means this encomium, a celebration
of the work of somebody, and which I always
start when you do one of these things, it's
a typical European intellectual deal is you
look at the things that they said and did
that had the most impact and it was most meaningful
to them in the same way.
Now, I didn't know Thích Nhất Hạnh.
I've worked very closely with the Dalai Lama
in the Tibetan Buddhist tradition, but the
Theravada Buddhist tradition I've never penetrated
personally and so I didn't know Thích Nhất
Hạnh.
But I do know the things that he said and
taught that really changed the way that Westerners
think.
And so that's what I wanted to talk about,
not what did he do that changed Theravada
Buddhism.
I'm not a Theravada Buddhist.
I'm not equipped to write that, but I can
talk about the way he changed me as a Catholic.
I can talk about how he changed me as a public
policy person because I was reading Thích
Nhất Hạnh when I was running a think tank
in Washington, DC.
How he influenced me as a happiness professor
at Harvard, that's the stuff that I really
wanted to focus on.
And that was the idea of attachment and detachment.
That was the idea of the illusion of individuality.
I mean, these are concepts that people didn't
think about.
He also was really behind the whole mindfulness
revolution in the West.
I mean, he starts off The Miracle of Mindfulness,
that famous book, big bestseller with this
simple description of washing the dishes.
And he says, "When you're washing the dishes,
you should be thinking about washing the dishes,
because if you don't think about washing the
dishes, you're not really there washing the
dishes, are you?"
And he persuades you with this hypnotic prose
to remember that if you don't think about
washing the dishes, but you're thinking about
doing something at work tomorrow or you're
thinking about something that happened yesterday,
that you're living in the future of the past
and you've missed your life.
Tim Ferriss: Or if you're thinking about eating
the juicy peach, which is a story — may
not have been in that book — that I remember
him telling, but it was paired with the washing
of the dishes.
Arthur Brooks: Right.
Tim Ferriss: He said, "If you're thinking
about the peach while you're washing the dishes,
when you're eating the peach, you'll probably
be thinking of something else as well."
Arthur Brooks: Exactly right.
And then what you're doing is while you're
doing this, you're planning for a future existence
that's better than now.
And when you reach it, it will be a phantasm
as well.
It will be nothing more than a mythical past
while you're thinking about a new future that
doesn't quite exist and you've missed your
whole life.
Tim Ferriss: How did he change you or influence
you as a Catholic?
Arthur Brooks: It's an interesting, and the
Dalai Lama too, by the way, I mean a lot of
Buddhist thinking has been incredibly helpful
to me to understand exactly what I'm trying
to do as a person when I'm centering myself
in prayer.
So for example, Catholics, traditional Catholics,
they generally pray what's called the rosary.
And the rosary is a set of beads that you
pray repetitive prayers.
It's about a thousand-year-old Catholic meditation.
I do it every day.
And I noticed that I was having a hard time
focusing.
I was having a hard time understanding what
I was trying to do for myself, for this offering.
I didn't know how to make it fruitful in its
way.
I didn't know exactly know what the point
was.
And studying the work of Thích Nhất Hạnh
and also studying at the Dalai Lama's monastery
in Dharamshala, India, sitting in meditation
and studying meditation techniques with the
Tibetan Buddhist monks, I actually learned
what I was supposed to be doing as a Catholic
praying my rosary, how I actually could center
my prayer and make it deeply worshipful in
a meaningful way, and perhaps God wanted me
to learn that from my Buddhist sisters and
brothers.
Tim Ferriss: This is going to be adjacent
to this conversation, this topic, but I'm
curious, do you believe that, and we can always
cut this, but I'm very curious, do you believe
that direct transmission in some of these
lines, which is very important, certain schools
of, we could call it mindfulness, but that
is a real phenomenon, or at least I suppose
it's undeniably important in the tradition,
but the idea that sitting with someone in
meditation with them, that there are teachings
that are directly transmitted.
What is your thought on that if you have?
Arthur Brooks: I don't know the answer to
that.
I do know that you can deeply be in communion
with somebody really intimately.
And my wife, Ester and I, we actually, we
teach young couples that are engaged about,
she teaches the theological part.
I teach the social science because I'm a total
wonk.
And what we do tell them is that according
to the best science and our experience and
common sense that one of the most intimate
things that you can do with your partner or
spouse is pray together.
It's super intimate.
I know couples that have been married for
25 years that will have sex together but won't
pray together because it's too embarrassing
to pray together because praying together
is just too intimate.
They don't know how to do it, it's embarrassing
to them.
Imagine you'll get naked in front of somebody
else, but you won't pray in front of them?
And that's because it's such a deeply intimate
thing.
So when you cross the boundary of the greatest
intimacy with another person, there's going
to be some transmission.
There's going to be something, and it's going
to — the idea of direct transmission rings
true to me because of the nature and intensity
of the intimacy that comes from that experience.
Tim Ferriss: We're going to take a hard left
for a second and we're going to come back
to a throughline which I am tracking, because
it's just what is top of mind for me.
And then we're going to come back to possible
mystical/semi-mystical experiences in Mexico.
So I'm giving an idea of —
Arthur Brooks: All right, I can't wait.
Tim Ferriss: Where in my head.
Arthur Brooks: I get to go to Mexico and have
mystical experience.
Tim Ferriss: The invitation is now formal.
But first, because for those who are not watching
this video, I mean you are incredibly physically
fit and I know that you have some very deliberate
consistent practices including weight training
and so on.
Blood occlusion training, are you still using
cuffs?
Arthur Brooks: I do, yeah.
And I recommend it for anybody over 40.
Tim Ferriss: Could you explain what this is
and why you recommend it?
Arthur Brooks: So occlusion training, what
it effectively does is it's not a tourniquet,
but what it is, it's a band around your arms
and/or legs so that when you're lifting, you
actually will get a much greater, as in the
vernacular, the burn, from resistance training
with lower weight.
Now, the reason I recommend this very strongly
is because the research suggests that it's
very good for both strength and hypertrophy
at lower weight levels so it saves your joints
but gives you results.
And that's what you need to do when you're
over 40, save the joints.
Tim Ferriss: And I really strongly encourage
people to check this out.
I've done some of it, and to say that it increases
the burn or the pump is certainly true.
Arthur Brooks: You've got a lot of pain.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, exactly.
Arthur Brooks: Got a lot of pain.
Tim Ferriss: I would say start conservative
because you might feel weak dialing back the
weights, but just wait.
It hurts, just give it a bit.
Arthur Brooks: It really does, but then you
learn to love the pain.
Tim Ferriss: And you can travel with, there
are cuffs you can travel with.
Arthur Brooks: I have them.
I carry them with me all the time.
I'm on the road 48 weeks a year.
Tim Ferriss: Is there a particular type that
you use?
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, I don't actually remember
the brand, but they're actually, they use
velcro and they're about two inches thick.
So too thick, and I actually can't get the
kind of occlusion that I really want.
So experiment with what works with the size
and shape of your biceps and triceps and then
learn how to use them and then make them tighter
and then get in touch with the pain.
Tim Ferriss: And they're easy to travel with.
Do your homework and start conservative.
Kelly Starrett, a very famous performance
coach and PT, is a friend, has been on the
show many times, introduced me to that.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, it's amazing, isn't it?
Tim Ferriss: And he had a very similar argument,
which is effectively, he doesn't say this,
but I would say you are as old as your joints
and connective tissue feel.
I mean, there's certainly a cognitive component.
And this is a really elegant way to preserve
or build muscle mass without risking integrity.
Arthur Brooks: I learned this from my friend
Sal Di Stefano, who started Mind Pump with
his partners.
Tim Ferriss: Mind Pump, what is it?
Arthur Brooks: Mind Pump, it's a fitness and
culture podcast and I've listened to it for
years and years and he taught me how to do
it.
He actually is, gives me training tips and
good ideas and now it's great.
It's been very helpful.
And by the way, when I was a younger man,
when I was in my thirties, I figured, what's
my goal with fitness?
And the answer is to still be lifting when
I'm 80.
To still be able to, why?
Because we know of all the health benefits
from it.
But the truth is that physical fitness, for
me, is a way to manage my negative affect.
It's actually a happiness technique for me.
It doesn't make me happier.
It makes me less unhappy.
That's what physical fitness will do — it'll
buy you less unhappiness.
And so I managed my negative affect that way.
And I know when I'm 80, I'm going to need
to manage my negative affect so I don't want
to hurt myself.
So I would go to the gym when I was 35 or
40 years old and I would go to these iron
gyms wherever I was traveling, and I would
find the oldest dude, the old guy who's still
lifting heavy things.
And I would go up to him, them, I say, "Can
I ask your advice?"
And they always want to give you advice.
The 76-year-old guy, he's like, "Don't bench
press.
It restricts your range of movement and that's
going to hurt.
You're going to get impingement injuries along
the way."
So that's why as you get older, you should
actually press with dumbbells and then do
higher rep to get volume, do higher reps with
lower weight, et cetera, and just sensible
stuff.
But it's actually been incredibly helpful
for me to not get hurt and stay in the gym.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, a hundred percent.
All right, so naturally, from the next place
—
Arthur Brooks: From the sublime to the ridiculous.
Tim Ferriss: Well, maybe ridiculous, maybe
not.
Arthur Brooks: Not for me, it's not.
That's for sure, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Could you please describe your
experience — I think it was as a teenager.
Was it as a teenager, in Mexico?
Arthur Brooks: Oh, yeah, the Mexican.
It was not out in the woods with a shaman
on ayahuasca.
When I was 15, I was on a band trip.
I used to be a musician and I started as a
kid.
I was a real serious musician, and I wound
up being a professional musician from when
I was 19 until I was 31.
Tim Ferriss: French horn?
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, I was a French horn player,
classical French horn player all the way through
my twenties.
I didn't go to college until I was 30, but
it was my gap decade.
And when I was —
Tim Ferriss: I need one of those, never too
late.
Arthur Brooks: And when I was 15 years old,
I was on this trip with a group with, not
a professional, it was an amateur concert
band, but doing a tour through Mexico and
we were doing a lot of tourism.
And one of the tourist activities was to go
to the Shrine of Guadalupe in Mexico City.
Now, this is a famous place for Catholics
because it's one of the great pilgrimage sites
of the world.
In Catholic teaching, this is where when the
Spanish explorers came to Mexico and having
a horrible time because their marketing was
all goofed up for the Catholic Church.
I mean, "Convert or die" is not a very compelling
fit, it turns out, and racist and everything
that you possibly could want.
What happens then is this weirdly miraculous
thing for Catholics and fellow travelers.
I mean, it was a mystical experience.
So there was a peasant man by the name of
Juan Diego who's on a hill outside of Mexico
City and sees an apparition of the Blessed
Virgin Mary.
So he on his poncho has imprinted the Blessed
Virgin Mary's image on his tilma, he takes
it back.
Tim Ferriss: Tilma is a textile?
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, it's a poncho.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Arthur Brooks: The tilma is what they would
wear.
And it was based on a fabric made out of cactus
actually.
And it's beautiful imprint, in color.
We've all seen the picture of, almost everybody's
seen the blessed Virgin Mary of Guadalupe
on this.
And if you google it, the Virgin of Guadalupe,
and you see it say, "Oh, I've seen that a
million times," because it's in every Latino
church.
And for the Catholic Church, she's the patroness
of all the Americas, including the United
States.
I mean, this is a big deal for the Church.
So the bishop sees it, they take the tilma,
they display the tilma in public, and for
the first time they start getting converts.
In the next nine years, seven million people
convert to the Catholic Church.
Now why?
There's worldly explanation, there's divine
explanations for it.
Here's a worldly explanation that's pretty
compelling.
Our Lady of Guadalupe is not white.
She's not Spanish, she's a mestiza.
She's a woman of mixed race.
Now, we don't realize today how incredibly
subversive that is.
How unbelievably culturally transgressive
that would've been.
"The Blessed Virgin Mary is not white?
What are you talking about?"
"No, no, no.
She's us."
"She's us?"
"She's every person in the world.
She loves you, she loves me, and she's one
of us because she's in all of us," and that
was this weird message that nobody really
would've thought of at the time, or so lore
goes.
And that's why people started saying, "Ah,
oh, this actually is for me because she actually
looks like me."
Crazy.
So anyway, so I'm in this church in Mexico
City, this Shrine of Guadalupe, and I'm looking
at the tilma.
Just sitting up there and I'm thinking, "This
is boring."
But then I noticed, she was looking at me.
She was looking at me.
Now to be sure, I didn't realize that you
can look at Elvis on velvet and the eyes will
follow you, right?
Okay, fair is fair.
But I couldn't get it out of my head.
I couldn't get it out of my head.
So worldly or divine or mystical or not, reasonable
people can disagree, but I couldn't get the
image out of my head, I couldn't.
And I realized I needed more in my life.
I needed a deeper sense of the metaphysical
in my life.
I needed the transcendent in my life.
And every time I thought of it, I thought
of that image.
And so I became a Catholic at 16 years old,
and I've been a Catholic man ever since.
Tim Ferriss: And did you have a family history
of Catholicism?
Arthur Brooks: Zero.
Tim Ferriss: Zero.
No, I grew up in a Christian family, so I
had a little bit of wiring, but I literally
knew no Catholics.
It's just this thing.
And my parents are like, "Ah, adolescent rebellion.
I guess it's better than drugs."
Tim Ferriss: It is better than heroin.
Arthur Brooks: And the point is, a lot of
people watching us, some are traditionally
religious and some are spiritual and some
are not.
But the whole point is we have a sense that
there's something else.
We have a sense that there's something deeper.
Let something in your life take you to the
deeper place.
Something needs to take you by the hand to
the deeper place.
There's a lot of research that suggests this
is the case.
Don't try to go to the deeper place to find
it randomly on your own, let someone take
you.
Now that insight, it's ambiguous.
But once people start to say, "I'm ready to
be taken to a deeper place, a more transcendent
state," that person, that entity will appear.
Tim Ferriss: We may come back to that, thank
you.
And I do think that many different paths touch
corners of the same thing is my impression,
which we may not have time for in this conversation,
but to be continued.
And the reason I'm asking about this experience,
for those people who are wondering how this
ties into maybe the headline of the podcast
is because I want to better understand the
influences and experiences that have shaped
you and your perceptual apparatus and your
thinking.
So another would be you've had multiple wake
up calls in your life, and as you described,
you didn't exactly have the linear path to
Harvard prof that people might've envisioned,
right?
Arthur Brooks: I got rejected from Harvard.
Tim Ferriss: Exeter, Harvard, McKinsey.
Arthur Brooks: No.
Tim Ferriss: Different path.
Arthur Brooks: I'd actually applied to Harvard
for graduate school.
And they're like, "No."
It took two weeks for them to reject.
Part of it is at the time I was 31, I was
a college dropout.
I had a degree from a correspondent school.
I was a French horn player.
These are not the core demographics of your
typical Harvard graduate student.
And so yeah, I got rejected, which suggests,
by the way, Tim, that our standards for faculty
today are lower than for our students.
But be that as it may.
Tim Ferriss: Maybe.
Maybe, I'm skeptical in your case.
I'd like to talk about your dad.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So who was your father?
What was he like and how did his life end?
Arthur Brooks: My dad was a mathematician,
he had a PhD in biostatistics.
He was a lifelong college professor, most
of it at a small Christian college in Seattle
called Seattle Pacific University.
He was born to missionary parents, evangelical
missionary parents.
He was born in the Navajo Nation in New Mexico
where my grandfather ran a mission school,
actually.
And then my grandfather went on to become
the dean of a very famous college outside
Chicago called Wheaton College where all of
our family members had gone.
My aunt went there in the '40s and dated Billy
Graham in college, as it turns out.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Arthur Brooks: And then my dad went on to
another Christian college, to the college
where he ultimately taught.
And he was just absolutely in love with the
beauty of mathematics.
As kids, my mother was an artist.
My mother was a painter, my dad was a mathematician.
And around the dinner table, we would talk
about art and we would talk about math.
Those are the things and my father would pose
math problems to us.
He would say, "Okay.
Okay, boys," me and my brother, "Imagine all
of the integers between one and 100, one,
two, three, four.
Okay, add them all together.
What's the result?"
And we'd be like, "I don't know.
I need a piece of paper."
He'd say, "No, you don't.
Think it another way.
Think of another way."
The solution by the way, is one plus a hundred
equals 101 and two plus 99 equals 101 and
three plus 98 equals 101.
And there are 51 of those, which makes what?
It makes 101 combinations.
51 combinations of 101.
Tim Ferriss: So that's how you —
Arthur Brooks: 5,050.
So that's what we would do.
That's what my father would do.
Tim Ferriss: You're like, "Dad, I'm just trying
to eat my macaroni and cheese."
Arthur Brooks: I know, I eat my macaroni and
cheese, and they would say something like,
"See, isn't that beautiful?
Isn't that beautiful?
Isn't that evidence of God?"
Tim Ferriss: That's what he or your mom would
say?
That's what he would say.
Arthur Brooks: My dad would say.
Tim Ferriss: The elegance of that.
Arthur Brooks: My dad believed not that what
we know is what we should pay attention to,
but to marvel at what we can do and still
not know anything.
So my father would explain, it had a big impact
on me, that there's two kinds of problems
in life.
There's complicated problems and there's complex
problems.
It's a mathematical difference, but the technique
doesn't matter.
Complicated problems are all the things that
you can solve with computational horsepower
and tech.
Complex problems are super easy to understand,
but you can never solve them.
Like who's going to win between the Patriots
and the Dolphins?
I know what winning looks like, it's more
points on the scoreboard, but I have no idea
and that's why it's beautiful to watch the
game and you don't want to simulate it on
a computer because it'll be inaccurate.
Love is complex.
A jet engine is complicated.
A cat is complex, a toaster is complicated.
And he said two kinds of problems.
And this he said as a basic math problem,
the reason that we're always unsatisfied in
life is because we have complex problems.
We want love, and all we have is complicated
solutions that the world is offering us like
computers and the internet and social media
and blah, blah, blah, blah.
And you'll never be satisfied because the
wrong kind of solution for the wrong kind
of problem.
Tim Ferriss: So that seems like a tremendously
valuable insight.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Would you describe your father
as a happy man?
Arthur Brooks: No.
My father was a gloomy man, and no doubt that
it had a lot to do with genetics, because
50 percent of our emotional baseline is genetic.
We know this from identical twin studies where
twins are born and separated at birth into
separate families.
This is not an experiment that social scientists
have done because that would be horribly unethical
but —
Tim Ferriss: Three Identical Strangers show
up, it turns out.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah.
Well, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: If you want to watch a brutal
doc.
Arthur Brooks: Oh, yeah.
That's a great documentary.
Tim Ferriss: It is great.
Arthur Brooks: But 50 percent of your baseline
mood, your tendency toward ebullience or gloominess,
is sitting in your DNA, and the result of
that is you need — this is the reason, Tim,
that I came to the happiness field, because
I saw my grandfather, who was a wonderful
man and gloomy, and my father, who was brilliant
and a lovely person and an excellent, ethical,
kind man who was gloomy, and I said, "No more,
man.
No more.
I'm going to live on the other 50 percent.
I am not going to be governed by that 50 percent
that made my father an unhappy man."
He died young, 66.
He had cancer, and they gave him 10 or 15
years or more, and he died in two.
As a statistician, he explained it.
He was a biostatistician by his graduate degree,
and I said, "Dad, it's terrible luck."
He said, "Look, there's got to be people on
that side of the curve, too."
He had a good sense of humor.
But the whole point was, he wasn't prepared
to fight for life because he didn't have the
hygiene for his own happiness.
That example set me on the path to learn about
this and to share these ideas, and it has
transformed my life.
I'm grateful to my father, and I will be for
the rest of my life, for the example that
he gave me and the lesson he taught me, even
through his unhappiness.
Tim Ferriss: What were some decisions you
made, or things you began doing or stopped
doing, after your father's death?
Arthur Brooks: I started exercising.
There is a little vanity to it, but not that
much.
The whole point of the matter is, this is
one of the single best ways to manage your
negative affect, is to be in the gym for an
hour a day.
Tim Ferriss: It's a bit dated probably, but
there's a book called Spark, which also goes
into a lot of BDNF, and a lot of the circuitry
and biochemical reasons for exercise for this
explicit purpose.
Arthur Brooks: When I'm working with students,
I put them through a battery of tests to look
at whether the bigger challenge in their life
is happiness or unhappiness.
The world is really scarce in the definitions
that it gives us, and there's a big mistake
that almost everybody makes about happiness,
which is, yeah, a lot of mistakes.
Number one, that it's the absence of unhappiness.
Number two, that it's a feeling.
Both of those are wrong.
Number three is that we can get it.
We can approach happiness, but we can't get
there because we actually need unhappiness,
and unhappiness and happiness are not opposites
and can coexist.
There's a lot to unpack from that.
To begin with, happiness and unhappiness,
in terms of moods, are largely processed in
different hemispheres of the brain.
A lot of neuroscientists believe that unhappy
cognitions and emotions are largely dominated
by activity in the right side of the brain.
The way that we know this, there's a terrific
neuroscientist at University of Wisconsin,
Richard Davidson, and he's done work that
shows that the left side of the musculature
on your face is more active when you're unhappy,
when you're experiencing negative emotions,
anger, fear, disgust, sadness, and it's actually
funny.
When my kids were little, I would notice that
when they fall down, you get a moment where
you don't know what's going to happen next.
Are they going to laugh and keep playing,
or you're going to get the waterworks, right?
The way to tell on that, because it's usually
five or six seconds, because the wiring in
their brain is actually not complete.
Tim Ferriss: It's a work in progress.
Arthur Brooks: One of the tests that I administer
to my students, and I put in my new book as
a matter of fact, because it's so important
for me and for understanding ourselves — it's
called the Positive Affect Negative Affect
Series, PANAS, P-A-N-A-S.
It's on my website, and it's easy to find.
I didn't create it.
It's been psychometrically validated a bunch
of times.
It's a great test.
What it does is it helps you figure out if
you're high-positive, high-negative, or low-positive,
low-negative, and there's four combinations.
It's a two-by-two matrix.
You can be a high-positive-affect person and
a high-negative-affect person.
That's a high-affect person who's got a lot
of strong moods about everything.
That's the mad scientist.
That's the mad scientist profile.
That's me.
I'm at the 85th percentile in happiness, happy
affect, and I'm at the 85th percentile in
negative affect.
Tim Ferriss: The highs are high and the lows
are low?
Arthur Brooks: Right, so I don't have a happiness
problem.
I have an unhappiness problem, is what it
comes down to.
It's not a problem, because unhappiness is
really important.
You won't be happy if you get rid of your
unhappiness, because you've got to be fully
alive to get happier, but you do need to manage
yourself.
Some people are really high-positive and really
low-negative.
Those are the cheerleaders.
Those people can't stay in the gym.
Why?
Because they don't feel better when they go
to the gym, because their negative affect
is already in the cellar.
The third is high-negative and low-positive.
That's the poet.
Nobody wants to be a poet, but the truth is
that the part of the brain called the ventral
lateral prefrontal cortex is highly active
for people who are sad and people who are
creative.
That's the reason when I say poet, you don't
think about somebody who's skipping down the
street, right?
You think of a creative person.
Tim Ferriss: “Life is shit,” with a cigarette
and a beret.
Arthur Brooks: Exactly right.
You're in a French cafe, thinking nihilistic
thoughts and writing poetry.
That's the poetic disposition, and the last
is low-low.
You could be perfectly happy or unhappy, but
you have low affect levels.
That's called the judge, the sober judge.
Tim Ferriss: I wish it were otherwise, but
I put high confidence that I am right down
the beret-wearing way.
How would you advise someone — and I know
this won't apply to everybody listening, but
just by way of a working example.
What does someone do with — what are their
options for how to act upon that?
Arthur Brooks: Okay.
If you know that you're a poet, this is a
very good — this is an affect level.
It doesn't mean that you're cosmically happy
or unhappy.
It just means that this is your natural disposition.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, right.
Arthur Brooks: So this is important, right?
It also means that you need to manage two
levers.
You need to manage your happiness levels up,
and you need to manage your unhappiness levels,
not to zero.
There's nothing wrong with unhappiness, but
you need to mute them.
You don't need to numb them.
You need to manage them.
Tim Ferriss: I may have already missed the
plot, but just define those two, because I
think a lot of people, myself maybe included,
would think, "If you remove unhappiness, by
default, since it's unhappiness — they seem
to be antonyms.
So you remove one, and you have more of the
other."
Arthur Brooks: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So how should we think about
these two?
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, yeah.
That's a very good question.
By the way, the answer is not obvious.
As a matter of fact, psychologists, until
about 50 years ago, really believed that unhappiness
was the absence of happiness.
But it's not true, because we actually find
that the basic negative and positive emotions
are coming from different parts of the limbic
system and can coexist.
Tim Ferriss: I see.
So if you're thinking about it, you can think
about it then sort of neuro-anatomically,
as opposed to semantically with the words.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, yeah.
And as a matter of fact —
Tim Ferriss: It's kind of like, not to dumb
it down too hard, but it's like if your left
hand performed X types of tasks and your right
hand performed Y type of tasks, it's like,
okay, you can sort of decide what ratio you're
aiming for.
Arthur Brooks: Right.
And your negative emotions are much more intense
than your positive emotions.
This has evolved to keep you alive.
Positive emotions are kind of nice to have.
Negative emotions are signals or alarms that
something might kill you.
A sweet smile from somebody across the room
is very pleasant, but a frowning face might
be somebody who wants to murder you.
Therefore, we've evolved to pay attention.
This is called the negativity bias that we
have.
We also have mixed states that we go through
all day long.
If you ask people in surveys what they're
feeling at any given moment, so you'll say
in five-minute increments, "What are you feeling,
positive or negative?"
you'll find that about 90 percent of the time
people can tell you how they're feeling.
In 40 percent of the time for the average
person, it's really pure positive emotions
at a low level.
It's your idle, is most of the time.
It's good.
Life's okay.
It's kind of sunny today, whatever, whatever.
All good.
About 16 percent of the time is pure negative
emotion, and that usually means something's
happening that you don't like.
Now, 33 percent of the time, you've got both.
And usually, the way that this looks in people's
lives is that you're in your positive idle,
but something's intruding.
So there's something bugging you that you
don't always remember.
And we go through life, and on a certain day
it's like, yeah, it's all good.
Oh, yeah, that thing.
And then you go back to kind of going back
to your positive idle, and oh, yeah, that
thing, that thing.
So that's the mixed state.
Tim Ferriss: Like Twitter.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, totally.
And by the way, I mean, it's an unhappiness
machine.
You mean X?
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
Sorry.
Exactly, X.
Arthur Brooks: A big black X.
You mean it's like X.
It's so appropriate.
So this is important because we understand
that these are separable phenomena.
We need both.
We need both these emotions, but we need to
be able to manage our emotions like pros,
and that's a lot of what I do.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, so what are some options?
So, I go through the PANAS, end up a “Poet.”
There are these two levers.
What might be the process of thinking through
how to pull these levers in different ways?
Arthur Brooks: The happiness side is what
I spend a lot more time on because it's just
so interesting on how we can pull the happiness
lever.
It starts by actually a good definition, which
is not feelings.
Feelings are evidence of happiness.
And thank God happiness isn't a feeling.
Can you imagine going through life chasing
a feeling?
That's awful.
It's like if it feels good, do it or some
— or if it feels bad, make it stop.
It's a terrible life strategy.
Happiness and its feelings are associated
with three tangible phenomena in our lives
that we can actually understand and manage:
enjoyment, satisfaction, and meaning.
Those are the three things that we need in
balance and abundance.
Think of these as the macronutrients of happiness,
the protein, carbohydrates, and fat of happiness.
If you don't have protein and carbohydrates
and fat in balance and abundance, all kinds
of weird things are going to happen to you.
And you're not going to be as healthy as you
should be, and you won't feel good.
The same thing is true.
You need to enjoy your life.
You need to get satisfaction from your accomplishments,
and you need to have a deep sense of meaning.
And each one of these is a big challenge.
When I meet somebody, through a series of
structured questions, I can figure out if
there's a problem along one of these macronutrient
dimensions.
And it turns out that there's some very easy
interventions that we can make across all
three, and I'll give you an example.
The first one is enjoyment.
So I say, "Do you enjoy your life?"
And they'll think about their little pleasures.
I say, "That's not it."
Pleasure is not a secret to happiness.
Pleasure is the fast road to obsessive-compulsive
activity and addiction.
Why?
Because all pleasure is is a phenomenon from
the limbic system of your brain saying, "Do
more of that thing because you're more likely
to survive and pass on your genes if you get
those calories, if you have that sex," whatever
it happens to be.
The way that you can actually turn that into
a source of happiness is by mixing in two
ingredients with your pleasure: people and
memory.
Never do something that gives you pleasure
alone.
That's the rule of thumb.
If you're doing it alone, it's a problem.
So Anheuser-Busch does a beer ad.
They never have in the beer ad —
Tim Ferriss: A guy drinking in his closet
—
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, a guy pounding a 12-pack
in his apartment alone.
Tim Ferriss: — listening to Pink Floyd.
Arthur Brooks: Why?
Because that's pleasure, and that actually
leads to addiction.
It's problematic.
They always have an ad of a guy cracking a
beer with his buddies, people, and doing something
he's going to remember.
Memory.
That's the secret to it.
So I'll take a survey of people's habits.
Now, this is the reason that pornography is
a big problem, right?
You're not consuming it in public with friends
to make a memory, for God's sake.
That's just sort of weird.
Tim Ferriss: Very rarely.
Arthur Brooks: That's a pretty weird thing
to do, right?
And that's one of the reasons.
I mean, it hits the dopamine lever.
I mean, they all are neurophysiologically
similar phenomena.
They hit dopamine, dopamine, dopamine, dopamine
over and over and over again, and they ruin
your life because they become addictive.
They become monomaniacal, and they're not
the secret to happiness.
If you're at 3:00 in the morning in Vegas
pulling the lever on the slot machine by yourself,
that's not the secret of happiness to anybody
I know.
And I've never heard somebody say, "You know
what gives my life happiness?
Methamphetamine."
Never been said, right?
And the reason for that is because these are
drugs.
People say drugs of abuse.
No, no, no.
These are drugs of pleasure.
Let's not lie about it.
They give you pleasure.
And pleasure alone, without memory, is a problem.
This is a very practical example of how we
can use the science and turn it into a set
of guideposts for our life.
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm.
So you have enjoyment, which you clarify.
Arthur Brooks: Satisfaction and meaning are
next.
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
How would you make satisfaction granular?
Because I think about satisfaction, and I'm
like, hmm, I might conflate being satisfied
with doing, say, a large project with some
form of meaning.
I can see how I might get my wires crossed.
So how should we think about these two in
your framework?
Arthur Brooks: Satisfaction is achieving something
with struggle.
It really is that project that you're talking
about, which it will give you meaning as well.
The project per se can actually cross the
boundaries across the macronutrients, just
like something that you eat has more than
one macronutrient.
But satisfaction per se is doing something
that takes effort and expending the effort.
So if my graduate students, they cheat to
get an A on an exam in my class, they'll get
the grade, but they won't get the satisfaction.
The satisfaction really comes from the pain.
This is one of the paradoxes of life.
You've got to suffer to get the satisfaction.
You've got to defer the gratification.
When somebody is on the pleasure mill, by
the way, they also don't get satisfaction
from anything because they can't defer their
gratification anymore.
These problems bleed into each other.
So one of the things that you find is that
people who are very accomplished, the people
— you are good at satisfaction because you
can defer your gratification and do long-term
projects.
You're a satisfaction guy.
The problem for you and me and a lot of people
who are going to watch your show because they
want to be better — I mean, nobody's watching
this show just for giggles.
They're watching this show because —
Tim Ferriss: We're not funny enough.
Arthur Brooks: They're watching your show
because they want to be better in their lives,
and so they're going to be good at deferring
their gratification and doing hard things.
Tim Ferriss: Or at least aspire to do that.
Arthur Brooks: Totally.
I mean, I've read your books.
It's not anything — it's interestingly deceptive.
The 4-Hour Fill-in-the-Blank, the early books,
it makes it sound like it's a hack and it's
easy.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Arthur Brooks: No.
Tim Ferriss: No, it's not.
Arthur Brooks: No, it's not.
The four hours is hard, is the point.
Those four hours are going to hurt.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, and there's a lot of front-loading,
right?
There's also hard work without forethought
and planning.
So there is built into any of those books
a strategic deferral.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, for sure.
So that's what brings satisfaction.
Here's the problem with satisfaction, and
this goes back to where we started the conversation.
Mick Jagger sang, "I can't get no satisfaction."
That's wrong.
You can't keep no satisfaction.
That's why you try and you try and you try,
and there's a reason for that.
Neuroscientists talk about homeostasis, which
is a phenomenon of always going back physically
and emotionally to your baseline.
And there's a reason for that, because you
need to go back to the baseline in your life
so you can be ready to react to the next set
of circumstances.
If emotionally you were going to be bummed
out for the rest of your life, you'd become
immobilized.
And if you felt super happy when something
good happened, you wouldn't be in the hunt
anymore.
Mother Nature wants you to think that you're
going to feel this emotion for the rest of
your life so that you will either avoid one
thing or pursue something, but she wants to
fool you and send you back again and again
and again and have you never figure it out.
Man, if I get that car, I'm going to love
it.
If I move to California, I'm going to enjoy
the sunshine for the rest of my life.
It turns out you get six months, by the way,
of enjoying weather, but the taxes are forever.
And that experience of never learning is called
the hedonic treadmill, and it's unbelievably
painful.
The way to solve that problem is haves divided
by wants.
The way to get real satisfaction is not having
more but wanting less.
And that's the reverse bucket list, et cetera.
That's the set of habits that helps you dominate
that particular science and short circuit
the loop that you're on because of Mother
Nature's plans for you, which are not really
in your happiness interests.
She doesn't care if you're happy, by the way.
Tim Ferriss: No.
Arthur Brooks: No.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, producing progeny is not
dependent on big smiles.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, it's like DNA, man.
It's all survival to pass on your genes, and
that's great for the propagation of the species.
It's not good for, I don't know, for pursuing
the divine path.
Tim Ferriss: We are going to come back to
meaning.
I want to just take a sidebar on reducing
wants for a second —
Arthur Brooks: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: — and talk about exercises
that you've had your students do in your classes.
And I'm pulling this from memory, so I may
not get the wording spot on, but identifying
their idols.
Am I getting this right?
Arthur Brooks: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So if you could expand on what
that looks like.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah.
We have a game.
I have a game show in my class at Harvard.
It's called What's My Idol?
Now, you can tell how old I am.
When I was a really little kid, there was
a game show on TV called What's My Line?
Your viewers can Google it.
I'm sure there's some black-and-white grainy
footage of it or something from when I was
in the '70s or back.
What's My Idol is actually based on the insight
of a medieval philosopher, St. Thomas Aquinas,
a theologian, but really a philosopher in
the Neoplatonic tradition.
Aquinas is responsible for introducing Aristotle
to the modern world.
Up until that point, nobody read Aristotle.
It was all Plato, Aristotle's teacher.
St. Thomas Aquinas, he said, "No, no, no,
no, no.
Guys, read this one.
This is the one."
Right?
And he interpreted Aristotle for the modern
world.
It was the same thing more or less that Averroes
was doing for the Muslim world and that Maimonides
was doing for the Jewish world, because they
were coexisting in southern Spain in this
intellectual soup.
That's hard for us to understand today, it
was so deep, what was going on.
St. Thomas Aquinas was an unbelievably adroit
social scientist.
He was also, by the way —
Tim Ferriss: A phenomenally impressive figure.
I mean, for people who aren't familiar, just
go read the Wikipedia entry and a few other
things.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, Right.
Tim Ferriss: It will blow your mind.
Arthur Brooks: And his magisterial work was
the Summa Theologiae, which is just — and
the way that he does it, by the way, it's
a master class in the way that we should be
thinking about big topics today, which is
by starting the topic with the best objection.
"Here's the question.
Here's the supposition.
What's the best objection?
Here's how I meet that objection.
What's the second-best objection?
Here's how I meet the objection."
The whole book is written this way.
It's unbelievable.
And in the section on human happiness, which
he pulls from Aristotle, who claims without
any need for proof — this is what we all
want, whether we act that way or not.
That there's four things that we do that distract
us from happiness.
Now, his definition of happiness is seeking
the divine.
This is what we all want.
What do you want?
The divine.
Do you know that?
Not necessarily.
Is it hard?
Yeah, and that's the reason we don't actually
act like we're pursuing the divine, because
pursuing God or the divine or the metaphysical
singularity or exterior consciousness or what
your thing is has a lot of one-sided conversations
and a lot of inconvenient morality attached
to it.
So we take these divinity substitutes.
These are the idols.
Biblically and in mythology, what idols all
have in common is that they're God-like, but
they're not God.
They're convenient substitutes for God.
That's all an idol is.
And St. Thomas Aquinas says, "There's four
substitutes for God," which we can think of
as the four substitutes for the real secrets
to happiness.
They are money, power, pleasure, and fame.
Tim Ferriss: How little things change!
Arthur Brooks: Ah.
And when he said fame, he actually didn't
say fame.
He said honor, but that has a different connotation
in English.
I have a son who's a Special Forces in the
military, and he serves with honor.
That's not what they mean.
Honor means to be honored.
It's fame.
It's reputation.
It's the admiration of other people.
Maybe it's Instagram followers or something
ridiculous, but it is something that we want
in the opinion of other people, and we thirst
after it.
And he says, "Everybody is motivated by one
thing."
And he'll even throw away comments, like,
"Communities, they coalesce around an idol."
It's so true.
We're recording this podcast in New York.
It's money, baby!
You go to a party in New York, and everybody's
like, "How's your fund this year?
How are you doing this year?
And how much does this apartment cost?"
It's all about money.
You go to L.A. What's the idol?
Tim Ferriss: Well, I'm not going to even call
it honor.
Fame.
Arthur Brooks: Fame, fame.
Okay, okay, let's keep with the quiz.
DC, what's the idol?
Tim Ferriss: Power.
Arthur Brooks: Power, man!
It's how close are you to the President?
What senator do you know?
Vegas?
Tim Ferriss: Pleasure.
Yeah.
Arthur Brooks: Right?
I mean communities will coalesce around this,
but each one of us has our idol too.
So here's the game.
You want to play?
Tim Ferriss: Sure, let's play the game.
Arthur Brooks: Okay.
So the truth is, none of us has all four.
None of us is so vice-ridden.
We don't have the energy or time to be serving
all four of these idols.
I mean, come on, life is short.
Tim Ferriss: You underestimate me, sir.
Arthur Brooks: But we all have one or two
that really animate us, and we don't always
know it because we're not paying attention
to it.
Now, Aquinas's point, and modern psychology
bears all this out, that as a normal adult
with a complicated life, if you know your
idol, you'll recognize the thing that always
leads you astray and leads you to do the things
that you later regret because you were following
that idol.
So it's very important to figure out which
idol that is so that you can manage it.
Not that you'll make it go away, because you're
human, but you can manage your idol.
Okay, so I start by saying, "What's not your
idol?"
Because of the four, there's something that
you could ditch.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Power is not — yeah, power immediately.
I'll name one to start with.
So that's —
Arthur Brooks: That's why you're not a CEO.
I mean, you've got a company, but you're not
trying to run a corporation.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
There's a lot of things that are — and I
know a lot of people who are power focused
in a sense, in one form or another.
It just doesn't —
Arthur Brooks: Do you dislike it?
Do you actively dislike power?
Like, people having power over you and you
having power over others?
Tim Ferriss: I don't dislike it necessarily.
I mean, I think that it's an inherent dynamic
in particularly chimpanzee politics, but just
in nature in general.
Arthur Brooks: Speaking of which, let me — react
to this phrase: Tim Feriss for Congress.
Tim Ferriss: No.
Arthur Brooks: There you go.
Tim Ferriss: Absolutely not.
Arthur Brooks: Your answer is correct.
You are not motivated by power.
It's the first one to get rid of.
Okay, you've got three left: money, pleasure,
fame.
You've got to kick one out.
You've got to get rid of one.
What's the next one to go?
Tim Ferriss: I can get rid of fame easily.
I think that there was a point in my life
where I sought a lot of social validation,
but having seen the flip side and the shadow
elements of that, it holds no —
Arthur Brooks: Well, you got pretty famous
young, and so you saw the dark side of that,
which is what social scientists and even neuroscientists
will tell you with their research is that
fame is really the only of the idols that
you can ever be happy in spite of.
When Lady Gaga tweeted, "Fame is prison,"
and everybody derided that, I'm thinking,
"That's deeply adept.
That is a deeply clarifying comment."
And by the way, I mean, John Milton wrote
that in the 17th century, that it is the idol
that we thirst after and sacrifice the happiness
of our days for that.
And you learn that by experience, not because
of disposition, because you did hunger after
it and then experienced it, and you realize
that it's a very, very, very bitter fruit.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
There are a lot of footnotes and a lot of
fine print in that Faustian bargain.
Arthur Brooks: Okay.
For 46-year-old Tim Feriss, that's number
two.
That goes out the door.
Tim Ferriss: Don't care.
In fact, if I could put the toothpaste back
in the toothpaste tube, in numerous ways,
I would do that.
Arthur Brooks: Right.
Okay.
You've got two left, and it's getting hot
in here, right?
Money and pleasure, wealth and pleasure.
Which one do you get rid of?
Tim Ferriss: I would say money, in the hierarchy,
I can get rid of.
The marginal utility of each additional dollar
just makes no difference in the things that
I care about.
Arthur Brooks: And a middle-class life wouldn't
freak you out?
Tim Ferriss: No.
At this point, I —
Arthur Brooks: I mean, I'm not talking about
poverty.
I'm not talking about not getting three squares.
I'm talking about not having the money for
the nice stuff that people think is really
wonderful to have: the houses, the boats,
the cars.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I don't really buy that
stuff.
Arthur Brooks: You don't care?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I don't really care.
And I care less and less, because also the
more financial success you have, the more
time you spend with people who have even greater
financial success.
And I've seen no indication, in fact, it might
even be a contraindication, that wealth produces
the things I'm after.
And I think there are significant adverse
side effects.
Arthur Brooks: Well, there's a lot of research
that shows that there is a way to buy happiness,
but it's not by buying stuff.
It's by buying experiences.
It's by buying time, or by giving it away.
And you already figured that one out.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Yeah.
I mean, quick example of that.
For me, in the last handful of years, I owe
Tim Urban a huge thank you for his article
"The Tail End."
I ended up booking most years, depending on
my family's health and so on, a family trip
once a year that we can look forward to for
six months and have group chats about and
so on.
And then even today, I was discussing a boys'
trip with some of my closest friends, probably
like six months from now.
Arthur Brooks: Great.
Tim Ferriss: And the ROI on those is huge.
But I would say money, I can get rid of money.
Arthur Brooks: So we found your idol.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, pleasure.
Arthur Brooks: Tim Ferriss likes to feel good.
Tim Ferriss: I do.
Yeah.
Arthur Brooks: Yep.
And again, there's nothing wrong with feeling
good.
But for you, we need to watch to make sure
that you're getting enjoyment and not pleasure.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Arthur Brooks: And we need to be very disciplined
about enjoyment and not pleasure.
Tim Ferriss: And I would also add to this
that I do think I'm a pleasure junkie for
certain things, the sensual, the sexual being
very high on the list.
There's also, I think, a wrinkle to this.
The sort of Mara sitting on my shoulder, if
anybody gets the reference, would be given
a history of depression, I fear its opposite.
So I chase pleasure as hopefully some inoculation
against darkness.
So there are many things contributing to that.
Arthur Brooks: Well, pleasure tends to be
numbing.
It does tend to be numbing of negative emotion,
so people will pursue pleasure because they're
actually trying to — it's fentanyl.
There's a reason that fentanyl — there's
nobody who enjoys fentanyl, because it's not
something you — like, "I'm going to go hang
out with my buddies and take fentanyl and
make a memory."
On the contrary, you're trying to eviscerate
memory.
You're trying to get rid of memory with these
types of things.
So numbing things tend to work that way, and
I understand.
I mean, you have a history of mood disorders
in your life, and you don't want them.
You don't want them back.
You don't want to invite them back, and so
you do something that feels like an inoculation
from those depths.
The key thing is that the real insurance policy
is enjoyment, satisfaction, and purpose.
That's the real insurance policy.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Arthur Brooks: And again, because it doesn't
eradicate the unhappiness, the darkness.
But it puts it into context such that it's
part of the bigger — the quilt of your life.
So it's just one square in the quilt of your
life and not the whole blanket.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
I want to expand on this because this is a
thread selfishly that I'd like to pull on.
Arthur Brooks: No, you've got it.
Tim Ferriss: And I will add maybe just one
thought, which is much of the pleasure that
I pursue is not numbing.
It's actually a — it's a volume competition
in the sense that if I start to feel like
there are whispers of the potential of an
onset of a depressive episode, or maybe it's
the ruminative thoughts and anxiety that comes
with that — but let's just say those are
at a two out of 10 volume.
There's fear because I worry that that is
going to spiral, and so I seek out something
on the positive side of the ledger, or let
me just say the pleasure side of the ledger,
that is higher volume.
Arthur Brooks: You're trying to knock yourself
out of a groove is what it comes down to,
right?
Tim Ferriss: It's like overcoming a dread
of deadness with greater aliveness.
Arthur Brooks: Right.
Now, what's one possible strategy that could
be a substitute strategy for that?
Tim Ferriss: Well, that's why I'm here, Doctor.
Arthur Brooks: And there are, right?
There are.
Meditation and prayer, seeking for the divine,
a serious spiritual practice, these are the
things that will actually do much the same
things, but without the numbing and without
the danger, without the — because it's tricky,
right?
I mean, hitting the dopamine lever has consequences.
Hitting it hard and often has desperate consequences
for it, and none of us needs problems in our
lives.
We have plenty of those already.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, totally.
So yes, and let's just say spare, meditation
— prayer.
Spare!
Spare prayer, the name of my forthcoming book.
Arthur Brooks: I like it.
Tim Ferriss: So prayer and —
Arthur Brooks: I like the sound of it.
Tim Ferriss: — and meditation.
With meditation, I can see the difference.
It's easy for, say, a secular listener to
consider.
Arthur Brooks: Right.
Tim Ferriss: What would you say to people
who are perhaps secular, not necessarily militant
atheists, who I think recognize, as I do — in
some ways, I am deeply, just to layer on my
sins here, envious of people who have strong
religious conviction.
I recognize the value.
And from at least in the sort of monotheistic
Judeo-Christian traditions, I don't think
I'm likely to join one of the bands.
Arthur Brooks: I'll work on you.
Tim Ferriss: So I recognize we can go do some
blood occlusion training and you can just
—
Arthur Brooks: And then we'll say a rosary
together.
Tim Ferriss: In between reps, lay the prayer
on thick.
So what would you suggest to me or someone
who recognize the value?
I do not have a counterargument, but I'm not
sure how to embrace that.
Arthur Brooks: There are alternatives.
I can tell you, as a Catholic, that that's
my thing.
But I can tell you as a social scientist that
it's not the only thing that will actually
bring the same neurophysiological and psychological
benefits.
What we need is a sense of the transcendent
that makes us small.
That's what we need.
Why?
Because we need perspective and peace.
I mean, Tim, you're going to go through all
day; it's like my podcast and it's my commute
and —
Tim Ferriss: Me, me, my, my, I, I.
Arthur Brooks: — my lunch, my money, and
my friends, and my mom, and my me, me.
Man, it's just so — it's like watching the
same episode every single night of Better
Call Saul for the rest of your life.
Tim Ferriss: It's like having the seagulls
from Finding Nemo in your head.
Mine, mine, mine, mine, mine.
Arthur Brooks: Me, me, mine, mine, mine.
I mean, it's the worst, and so you have to
find a way to get peace.
But what we really need is to put ourselves
in perspective.
Now, most people are afraid to be little,
are really afraid to be insignificant.
Perspective requires that we see reality,
and we get smaller, and we stand in awe of
the universe and what it can bring.
There's lots of ways to do that.
Meditation practices are very good for that.
Prayer is very good for that.
Religion, under most traditional circumstances,
is very good for that.
But walking in nature without devices before
dawn for an hour is incredibly good for that,
for all sorts of reasons.
And this is extremely well-validated in the
social science literature.
Tim Ferriss: How important is the timing on
that?
Arthur Brooks: Well, it's good because you
start the day that way, and it's the programming
of it.
And by the way, the experience of seeing the
sunrise is incredibly awe-inspiring.
Plus, it's quiet and cool.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, all pleasant.
Arthur Brooks: Quiet and cool, for sure.
And therefore, you get just a bigger bolus
of the benefits that you actually get from
being in contact with the Earth and being
in contact with nature, et cetera.
Another way to do this is to stand in awe
of human genius.
That's way outside the realm of your experience.
So learn about the fugues of Johann Sebastian
Bach.
Read about his life.
Tim Ferriss: Your favorite.
Arthur Brooks: Oh, yeah.
And listen to a hundred of his cantatas and
learn how to analyze them.
I mean, your life will never be the same.
Or your neighbor and our mutual friend, Ryan
Holiday, read the Stoics.
Read the Stoics.
I mean, it's a quasi-religious experience.
You will feel a deep satisfaction at your
littleness probably for the first time in
years, as a matter of fact.
There are many ways to get this, but you need
to get small in front of Bach, in front of
Epictetus, in front of God.
You need to get small, is the whole point.
Tim Ferriss: I love that.
It's easy to remember, right?
Get small.
And just to underscore that for myself, I
mean, a few things that have been helpful.
Nature, yes.
Arthur Brooks: Yes, for sure.
Tim Ferriss: Studying or it could take the
form of listening to, say, Hardcore History
and listening to "Kings of Kings," the Assyrians,
and really widening the aperture of your historic
lens, just to put the problems of this week
in perspective.
And also the impermanence of empires may be
relevant these days.
Arthur Brooks: This is a moment in time and
— yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
So going back and realizing some of the most
powerful figures in the history of humankind
you will not recognize, which also, I think
for me, has been very relieving and also has
taken a lot of the earlier fixation on money
away because I realize it's just ashes to
ashes, dust to dust, right?
Arthur Brooks: To quote the Ecclesiastes.
Tim Ferriss: That's right.
Give me the full name of Alexander the Great.
Most people can't.
So rather than get fixed on some vague notion
of legacy, let's actually focus on other things.
The getting small: looking at the stars, honestly.
I did so much as a kid, and I lost it and
have sort of reclaimed as this thing that
can be used as such a tool for zooming out.
And I have two friends.
Ed Cook is one notable example, who when he
thinks of his problems, and I'm going to paraphrase
this, but he will look at the stars and sort
of zoom out from his neighborhood, himself,
to the planet, to the solar system.
And when he then returns back to laying on
the ground, looking at the stars, the problems
that were plaguing you just do not seem —
Arthur Brooks: That's the point.
Tim Ferriss: — so significant.
Arthur Brooks: That's really the point.
It's not just a question of minimizing your
problems.
It's also minimizing the scale of your hopes
and dreams and opportunities and recognizing
that what really matters, you're in that,
to be sure, but you're one part of that.
It's okay.
It's all okay.
The great is just okay, and the bad is okay
too.
And that's so deeply comforting, and it leads
to so many improvements in mental health.
I just don't know how you can put one foot
in front of the other without doing something
like this every day.
Now, people often ask, "Okay, how do I get
started?
How do I get started?"
Read 15 minutes a day.
Pick up The Brothers K.
Tim Ferriss: The Brothers Karamazov?
Arthur Brooks: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Am I saying that — probably
not.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, you are.
The Brothers Karamazov by Fyodor Dostoevsky.
If you like fiction, stop wasting your time
on trivialities.
Go get The Brothers K. Why?
Because it's a deeply awe-inspiring experience
about the human condition and the absurdity
of it.
It's beautiful.
Get the Meditations of Marcus Aurelius, who,
by the way, a world historical figure because
he was a Roman emperor.
Nobody remembers practically a single thing
that happened as Roman Emperor.
We remember what was written in his private
diary.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it's wild.
Arthur Brooks: It's craziness.
Tim Ferriss: Last of the great emperors.
Arthur Brooks: It's mostly because he was
dumb enough to leave his son in charge.
Tim Ferriss: Oops.
Arthur Brooks: His wastrel.
Tim Ferriss: That's like the story of humankind
also.
Arthur Brooks: Speaking of which, I think
I want to leave my business to my kids.
What do you think, Tim?
Tim Ferriss: There's a long conversation,
knowing how kids are —
Arthur Brooks: My kids are awesome.
I wonder if I can get them into the happiness
business.
Tim Ferriss: "Dad, I know you're always beating
us over the head on this happiness business.
It's not my path.
It's your path."
Arthur Brooks: Eye roll.
Tim Ferriss: So I am curious for you personally,
having thought about this deeply, having tracked
a lot of things also, what are some of the
best uses of money that you have found personally?
What types of things?
Are there any concrete examples that you can
give?
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, so we rolled through
that fast just a second ago, but it turns
out there's a ton of research on this.
My colleagues, Mike Norton and Ashley Whillans
at the Harvard Business School, they've done
this exhaustive research on how to buy happiness,
how to buy happiness, right, okay?
And Mother Nature says, "Get more stuff."
"Why?"
"Because satisfaction comes from having more."
"What's the strategy for life?"
"More."
Mother Nature tells you that.
She lies, she lies.
Lies and lies and laughs at you.
That's not the strategy.
You need to buy enough, but no possession
will do anything beyond bring you out of misery.
That's the reason that the famous Kahneman
and Deaton study from Princeton shows that
happiness flattens out after $75,000 a year.
And Matt Killingsworth at Penn actually reran
the data and finds that it's higher, but it
still flattens out.
Tim Ferriss: Inflation-adjusted, but still.
Arthur Brooks: Inflation adjusted or your
results may vary or whatever it is, but the
whole point is you just don't get happier
and happier and happier is millions.
The reason, by the way that we think that
is an illusion that comes from our experience,
most people have less than they perceive that
they need when they're young.
And the result of it is that a lot of people
and a lot of people listening to us, they
suffer a lack of meeting some basic needs.
When I was 19 to 25, I was too poor for six
years to go to the dentist, for six years.
Now, of course, I don't think I ever went
a day without cigarettes, so I guess it was
priorities.
But the point is that when I was —
Tim Ferriss: Breakfast of champions.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, beer, cigarettes, pizza.
I was living in Washington Heights in those
days.
And when I was 25, I took a job in the Barcelona
Orchestra and I moved to Barcelona, had benefits.
I had bennies, man, and I went to the dentist
and he filled 10 cavities, and I felt a lot
better.
And I thought, money does buy happiness.
No, no, no, money lowers unhappiness when
you move out of deprivation.
That's it.
And so what happens is I made the mental link
between getting money and feeling better.
And people do that, and they chase that feeling
for the rest of their life.
Because you're doing sums in your head of
well-being is happiness and unhappiness and
all that.
You can't tell the difference when you're
just rolling through your life and early on
you felt a lot better.
That's all you know when you had more money.
And so you want that feeling and you chase
the feeling.
You chase the high, you chase the early hits.
It's like drugs, like any other drugs in this
way.
So that doesn't work.
There are three ways you can buy happiness
according to Whillans and Norton, my colleagues
at HBS, you can buy experiences.
This is critically important because what
do experiences that where you buy happiness
really have in common?
You add money, which is sort of like pleasure.
But the really important parts are the people
in the memory.
People in memory, people in memory are always
part of experiences.
Okay, now, sometimes you want to do things
alone, but generally speaking, the greatest
happiness comes because it enhances love in
your life.
The best way to improve love in your life
if you want your love life with your partner
to get better, go away together.
Go away together.
That's always the best way to do it.
Or stay home together, but turn off the phone.
In other words, get an experience with the
person that you love.
That's a great way to spend money because
it will reliably, unless you waste it, do
something stupid.
Like I'm going to have a bender in Vegas and
then get blackout drunk and sit in front of
the slot machine.
That's not the secret.
But being prudent, you can actually buy happiness
through experiences.
That's number one.
Number two —
Tim Ferriss: I'm going to ask you for personal
examples, but yes.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I'm serious.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, for sure.
Buy time.
But use the time correctly.
If you have the money and you're cutting your
lawn and you don't like cutting your lawn,
improve GDP, hire a guy.
Now, a lot of Americans don't like to do that
because they have this kind of this weird
reverse-classist sense.
Well, let me tell you, there's a lot of people
who are making more money than you cutting
lawns and running a gardening service.
Spread the love, give somebody a job, and
then use the time correctly.
Don't fritter away your time scrolling social
media in the house, in the air conditioning.
No, no, no, use the time specifically for
something, ideally with somebody doing something
that you enjoy and that will truly buy happiness.
And last but not least, give your money away
to somebody who needs it, who deserves it,
and a cause that truly inspires you, something
you really believe in.
I've studied philanthropy long before I studied
happiness.
I was an academic beavering away in obscurity,
writing books on charity and philanthropy
and nonprofit organizations.
And the reason I initially got into happiness
in the first place, besides wanting to be
happy, was that I found that the more people
gave, the happier they got.
Tim Ferriss: So we don't have to tread into
these waters, but I think it would be very
helpful for people, and I'm very curious,
I'm happy to reciprocate also, where have
you landed for where to give your own money?
Arthur Brooks: I give money to things that
I really care about that I think have an impact
on people's lives in a big way.
And a lot of what I do is I give to education,
to people who are at the margins of society.
So I give a lot to primary and secondary education,
specifically to Catholic primary and secondary
education because I think it's really well
done, and it's an option that a lot of people
don't have access to because it costs money.
So a lot of what I do, probably 75 percent
of what I give away, and I give away 10 percent
of my income so —
Tim Ferriss: Good for you.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, because it's not that
hard to do.
You just have to pay attention to it.
And then there's structures.
So you get a charitable giving account.
Tim Ferriss: Do you think of that as a tithe
or —
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, I do think of it as a
tithe, but I really think of it as a privilege.
I think of it a lot less as a duty and a lot
more as a privilege.
My wife and I, we just look forward to it.
And then we have a process in our family of
should we give money to this?
Should we give money to that?
Usually we give something kind of a big bolus
one year, and then smaller gifts to things
that are ongoing sources of support that we
really believe in.
Tim Ferriss: How do you decide what to give
to?
Arthur Brooks: Well, we know the people and
we do the work, right?
So it's not just anybody, we get a letter
in the mail and we respond with a big check.
It's like, huh, that seems worthy.
No, we actually do the work.
And part of it's, one of the classes I teach
at Harvard is on nonprofit management.
And so I have kind of a strong background
and whether it's a reputable cause and what
to look for into measuring the effectiveness
of an organization.
So I do the work, I do the background work.
I see what kind of overhead rates that they're
using, how they're using their money.
A lot has to do with, if I like the mission.
Sometimes if it's going to be a substantial
amount of money, I get to know the people
and the organization.
And it has to be something that I think is
going to change people's lives for the better.
Now, I've actually changed my view on this
a little bit because early on we'd write a
lot of little checks, lots and lots and lots
of little checks to great organizations.
And then I found that you can have a lot more
effect on your own well-being.
And again, this is kind of selfish, but in
your own well-being, by concentrating on turning
the whole dial in one person's life that you
can really — so really.
And there's an old Talmudic phrase from the
book of Sanhedrin that says, "In every man
is the whole world," right?
In other words, turn the dial for one person,
you've turned the dial for all of humanity
because it's really had an impact.
I remember telling my wife about that.
It's, "Yeah, I've got these data that when
you really help one person instead of a little
bit for a lot really anonymously, you can
get all these benefits."
This is years ago.
This is maybe 20 years ago now.
And she's, "Why don't we adopt a baby?"
And I'm, "It's only a book, man."
But we did.
We actually did.
It was totally life-changing.
Totally life-changing.
Tim Ferriss: So I think I missed a hop.
Arthur Brooks: So that's how you give.
You've got to do the work and think about
it and put your heart into it.
And philosophical —
Tim Ferriss: Could you say more about that,
how did she come to the adoption?
Arthur Brooks: My wife?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, how did she —
Arthur Brooks: She came to it because I was
saying, you get a lot more benefits when you
turn the whole dial on one person's life as
opposed to just throwing dollar bills at a
helicopter.
Tim Ferriss: So she was, Spinal Tap, "Let's
turn this to 11."
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, she's basically, "Okay,
buddy, you really, really…"
this was, "...I know you've got this interesting
research, fancy social scientist guy, let's
see.
Should we put our money where our mouth is?"
And by the way, she had also been having dreams
about a little girl who was abandoned.
Dreams and dreams and dreams at night.
Tim Ferriss: Can you tell me more about your
wife and how you guys met?
Because I know a little bit of the background,
but how did that happen?
Since I'm back on the playing field.
Arthur Brooks: Back on the playing field time.
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm —
Arthur Brooks: One of the things that I teach
my students at HBS is that I would never invest
in the firm of an entrepreneur who's unwilling
to give her or his heart away.
Because it's the single most risky entrepreneurial
thing that you can do, putting every bit of
capital at risk.
If you're not willing to give your heart away,
I'm not going to put my money in your fund.
Now —
Tim Ferriss: And that takes the form of —
Arthur Brooks: Risk, man.
Tim Ferriss: Loving someone wholeheartedly.
Arthur Brooks: Giving your heart away.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
And the reason I believe this is because I've
always had this sense that part of the journey
of life is just getting in it, getting in
it.
And entrepreneurs talk a lot about putting
capital at risk and talking about money, how
boring.
The real capital of the enterprise, the startup
of Tim Ferriss's life because this is the
ultimate enterprise — the enterprise is
not the podcast and the books and the company,
and that's not it.
Those were manifestations of Tim Ferriss Inc.,
of you.
The enterprise is you, and the currency of
you is not money, it's love and happiness.
That's your currency.
So how are you going to put that at risk for
explosive, tectonic, inflecting returns?
What are you going to do to put it at risk?
That's the question.
And the answers are really tricky, but the
one answer that's not right is don't put it
at risk.
Don't put it at risk.
Tim Ferriss: Right, so I'm with you.
Now, there are myriad ways that if you were
to sort of take off your flak jacket and just
walk into oncoming traffic with emotional
oncoming traffic with someone who you've been
on a dating app who you meet within five minutes
and they're cuckoo bananas, that could turn
out poorly.
Arthur Brooks: Of course, that's just Vegas.
That's not entrepreneurship, that's just gambling.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Well, first I want to hear your story.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, so this gets back to
thees issue at hand.
And the reason I did that little prelude is
because I don't want anybody to think that
my screws are too loose, right?
Tim Ferriss: That's not my goal.
And finally —
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, it's insanity.
So okay.
Tim Ferriss: I rest my case, insane man on
the podcast.
Arthur Brooks: Deeply unbalanced guest joins
Tim Ferriss.
When I was 24 years old, I was on a concert
tour and I was making my living as a classical
French horn player.
I was on a concert tour in the Burgundy region
of France, ended up going from town to town,
playing concerts.
And I was staying at this school.
I don't know, it's just where we were housed
during this.
We were going out from there.
And at the same time, there was a music festival
going on, and there were musicians from all
over Europe that were studying at this music
festival.
And I was at this concert playing at this
very school and playing my horn, looking out
in the audience.
And there was this girl smiling at me in the
front row, beautiful girl smiling at me, just
gorgeous.
And I'm a red-blooded 24-year-old dude, and
obviously, I'm going to make a mental note
to go talk to her.
So I go to talk to her later, and I find out
two things, two things.
Number one, she's not French, even though
I was in France.
And number two, that she doesn't speak a single
word of English.
And it was hard because I was trying to talk
to her in monosyllabic grunts and the fruitless
search for cognates.
And I said, "Are you single?"
This is like this basic, "Are you single?"
And she says, "Yes, I'm divorced."
I'm not down with that.
But what she meant was "I just broke up with
my boyfriend," but she couldn't come up with
any Latin-based words besides divorce, which
actually comes from Latin to try to get me
to understand this point.
Anyway, so it was a comedy of errors.
And we went out to dinner and we went on some
dates, and I left after a week, and I went
home and I called my dad in Seattle.
I grew up in Seattle, and I was living in
New York at the time.
I said, "Dad, I think I met the girl I'm going
to marry."
Tim Ferriss: And where was she from?
Arthur Brooks: Barcelona.
Barcelona.
And he said, "Great, let's meet her."
And I said, "I've got problems.
Problem number one is that she doesn't live
in the United States.
Problem number two is she doesn't speak a
word of English.
Problem number three is that she made me aware
that she doesn't believe in marriage because
she thinks it's an anachronistic institution
and she's never going to get married."
Tim Ferriss: It's a hell of a —
Arthur Brooks: Yeah —
Tim Ferriss: It's a concept to communicate
in Tarzanese.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, no, for sure.
We were together for a week and we —
Tim Ferriss: You got there.
Arthur Brooks: We got there.
And I couldn't get out of my head.
It was like our Lady of Guadalupe kind of.
I thought about it.
And we exchanged letters and weirdly somehow
talked on the phone.
She started taking English classes, I started
studying Spanish.
Who knows when I'll see her?
I traveled to Barcelona, saw her, she came
to New York and visited me, just a little
bit here and there.
And what I didn't tell her is that I had quit
my job in New York and I'd won an audition
to be a member of the symphony in Barcelona,
because I wanted to go see if I could close
that deal.
If I could change her philosophy of marriage.
It took me two years, but I closed the deal.
And 32 years later, we have three adult kids
and one grandson, and I'm still in love.
Tim Ferriss: So how did you end up debate
teaming that?
I'm just curious.
How did —
Arthur Brooks: I just wore her down?
Tim Ferriss: You just wore her down.
Arthur Brooks: I just wore her down.
So living in Barcelona, she was in love with
me.
And so she's not like, "Get out," it's not
like I was some weird stalker.
She really was in love with me and she wanted
to be with me, but nobody in her family was
married.
This is not what you do in Barcelona.
Tim Ferriss: I didn't realize that.
Arthur Brooks: Because it sounds like a big
Catholic country.
It's a post-Christian country.
Three percent of the population of Barcelona
ever goes to Mass.
Three percent.
Tim Ferriss: I never would've guessed that.
Arthur Brooks: It's Denmark in the Mediterranean.
Tim Ferriss: That's incredible.
I had no idea.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, nobody does for sure.
But it has a long tradition.
And she comes from a hard, red, communist
atheist family.
So suffice it to say that our backgrounds
are a little bit different.
Again, she was beautiful and smart, funny,
and I was in love.
And just love will out, love will out.
And finally, at the end of two years, finally
I said — I got down on one knee and I said,
"Are you ready to change your mind?"
She said, "Yes."
Tim Ferriss: All right, so once again, envy
has showed its ugly head.
And I have to admit my French horn game, very
weak.
Very weak.
Arthur Brooks: Turns out the French horn is
the least of it.
Tim Ferriss: Tight pants, big guns.
Arthur Brooks: In those days, 6'2 and 142
pounds.
My wife said that it was like hugging a tight
sack of rocks.
Now she says it's like a loose leather bag
of ropes.
So I've made some progress.
Tim Ferriss: Hey, yeah.
Arthur Brooks: Is that progress?
Tim Ferriss: It sounds like progress, I don't
know.
Arthur Brooks: Leather bag of ropes.
Tim Ferriss: Maybe that should be on my dating
profile.
If you hug me, I feel like — maybe not.
That's a little too Silence of the Lambs.
Arthur Brooks: Babies fighting under a blanket.
I don't know.
Tim Ferriss: And maybe you're so far removed
that this doesn't make sense to ask, but what
advice — also, you're coming from a different
orientation with the Catholicism, and I assume
maybe wrongly, but I imagine your wife —
Arthur Brooks: It was mine but not hers.
Tim Ferriss: Right, now, is she fully aboard
the Catholic train?
Arthur Brooks: Fully aboard.
But that took a long time.
Tim Ferriss: Wore her down.
Arthur Brooks: A lot of prayer.
As they say, this is one of those problems
that requires prayer and fasting.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
So you prayed and she fasted, and you're like,
no food.
“It will put the rosaries on its wrist.”
All right.
Thoughts on how to find a partner?
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, no, I think about this
an awful lot because this is the number one
topic in my Science of Happiness class at
HBS that they want to know about.
Tim Ferriss: It's got to be.
Arthur Brooks: Oh, for sure.
Absolutely.
Because not only is this something that we
all want, that everybody wants, it's something
that's getting harder.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, all the traditional scaffolding
is gone unless perhaps you're part of, say,
a Jewish community where that type of Yenta-like
matchmaking is sort of a very esteemed role.
Arthur Brooks: But even then, the modern world
is encroaching on that.
And if you look at the comparison between
in the '80s when I was in my twenties or the
'90s when you were in your twenties — sorry,
I didn't mean to shock you with that.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, that's okay.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, I know.
It's much harder.
Tim Ferriss: I have the ring of Frodo, so
I'm not planning on aging anymore from this
point forward.
Side note, you should look at photos of him
now and 20 years ago, they're the same, the
actor, anyway.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah.
Not me, though.
Tim Ferriss: For those conspiracy theorists
out there.
Arthur Brooks: Back when I was in the Barcelona
Symphony, I had this hair.
It was like a great civilization.
Tim Ferriss: It's like the locks of Samson.
Arthur Brooks: That was unbelievable.
And then I started going bald.
I'm getting more and more bald.
And my brother, my older brother, he is very
judgmental about me, he's funny, he loves
me, but he says, "You deserve it because of
the life you've led."
Tim Ferriss: "Et tu, Brute."
Arthur Brooks: It's just a lot of DHT, man.
Anyway, so what are the guardrails?
What are the mistakes that we make?
What's actually making it harder?
And there's a lot of things that go into it.
The fact that we're using tech where we would've
used humans is deeply problematic.
The fact that we have so much deal flow is
making it harder.
The paradox of choice is a real thing.
Better, better, better, better.
There's a ton of research on this, by the
way, Tim.
You've seen some of this research, for example,
on car purchases where you give two groups.
There's the treatment and control social science
experiments, two groups, different car buying
experiences.
For the first, buys their car and there's
no refund and there's no returns.
And the other side can return it for any reason
in the next six months.
And the first group is much happier with their
car because they're not thinking about it
again and again and again.
There's no more swiping on their car purchase.
And so the same thing is when it's very easy
to have a lot of selection, it gets much harder
to attain satisfaction.
Tim Ferriss: You're also exhausted more easily
because of the decision fatigue.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah.
I'll have to take your word for it, but that's
certainly true.
That's in the data.
Tim Ferriss: Well, I'm saying not outside
of dating, just in general.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Arthur Brooks: But the bigger problem actually
comes because we're looking for the wrong
thing in a partner.
The data suggests that what everybody wants
in a partner that they can curate carefully
because of the online presence, because of
the platforms, is they want compatibility
and they look for compatibility with sameness
to them.
So, "I like this kind of food.
You do too?
Great.
I vote like this.
You do too?
Great.
I'm this religion, or I'm no religion.
I grew up here.
I went to college.
Where did you go to college?"
Et cetera.
Tim Ferriss: They're not looking for someone
who doesn't speak their language, who is —
Arthur Brooks: They're looking for a sibling.
And as my adult kids would say, "That's not
hot."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Arthur Brooks: The truth is we're way too
compatible and we're sorting on compatibility
with these technological means.
And the biggest problem with dating today
is we're less and less attracted to people.
We're less and less attracted because they're
too much like us.
We need more complementarity and less compatibility.
Back in the old days, you used to say opposites
attract, not true, but you need a baseline
of compatibility.
But on top of that, you need difference.
Difference is hot.
Difference is fun.
Difference is an adventure, and you're just
not going to find it because nobody's going
to swipe on you, quite frankly, if you're
the other party.
And a lot of people curate on language and
culture and race, it's insanity.
That's the reason that good old-fashioned
human people who say they could fall in love,
when you talk about people who fix you up
on a blind date or the old-fashioned matchmakers,
they're always looking about complementarity.
This introvert and this extrovert can fill
in the gaps in each other in a kind of divine
and cosmic way.
And that's kind of how I always felt.
That's how I always kind of felt.
I felt like my wife was — I don't believe
in magical thinking on this.
Magical thinking is a big problem because
soulmates don't exist and there's no such
thing as love at first sight.
But I always do feel like my wife, Ester,
she was picked for me.
She was really picked for me and because of
the difference as much as anything else, She
completes me.
She makes me a better man.
She knows when I'm going after the idol, she
can see it going after the lore.
She can see it.
She's like, "Mmm, right."
And that's 32 years of experience together.
But it's also the deep complementarity that
came through because I was born at a particular
time and I accidentally had this kind of experience,
and that's what we need.
That's number one.
This is clear.
The second thing is goals.
Goals.
And I ask people, "You're going to meet the
person of your dreams, or the good-enough
person, or whatever; what do you want to have
after five years?"
Tim Ferriss: The good-enough person.
Tim Ferriss’s Guide —
Arthur Brooks: The good-enough wife.
Tim Ferriss: — to Passable Relationships.
Arthur Brooks: Wife me up with someone good
enough, man.
Anyway, so yeah, I know.
Because by the way —
Tim Ferriss: Step one, their criminal record.
Just kidding.
Arthur Brooks: I don't know, man, complementarity.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, maybe.
Arthur Brooks: It's like, "You've been in
prison, I haven't.
We complete each other."
Tim Ferriss: Clearly whatever I've been trying
isn't working.
Maybe I'll skip Barcelona and do the prison
circuit.
All right.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah.
But when you ask people "What do you want
your relationship to look like in five years?"
They have this magical notion of an ongoing
passion.
And that's the wrong goal.
The right goal is what is called companionate
love.
You want to be best friends in five years.
Five years to best friends, that's the goal.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I like that.
Arthur Brooks: And if you write it out and
if you actually make it the goal and then
you have interim steps, then a strategic plan,
you might just get there.
But if you're like, yeah, no, it's like if
the magic feels like the magic's gone, obviously
there's something wrong with our love.
No, best friends who are married, they're
going to have plenty of passion, but you can't
live like that.
Look, the neurophysiological cascade of the
experience of falling in love is unbelievably
intense.
It's 4th of July in your head.
The bolus of testosterone and estrogen at
the very beginning of the relationship, that
massive increases in norepinephrine and dopamine
that give you euphoria and concentration and
focus on the other person, the deep dip in
serotonin, your serotonin dips.
Why?
Because you want to ruminate on that person
using the good old ventral lateral prefrontal
cortex.
That's the reason that falling in love is
an awful lot like being clinically depressed.
So you're both addicted to meth and depressed
at the same time.
That's what falling in love is like.
And then you're going to get that big, big,
big dose of oxytocin, which is the neuropeptide
that links you to the other person in this
almost magical, confusing way.
Man, that's just too much.
You don't want that for the rest of your life.
Tim Ferriss: Sounds like a lot.
Arthur Brooks: Well, you'll be institutionalized.
Tim Ferriss: All right, so let's pause there
for a second.
Arthur Brooks: That was a lot.
Tim Ferriss: It was a lot.
Arthur Brooks: Are you overstimulated?
Tim Ferriss: I want to go from falling in
love as meth and depression to the lightness
of death.
Arthur Brooks: And we haven't even talked
about meaning yet, man.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, we're going to get there.
Arthur Brooks: We'll get there by the ninth
hour.
Tim Ferriss: I'm keeping track.
Arthur Brooks: Hour nine.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I'm keeping track.
Hour nine, I have it bookmarked.
Also, I have a promise I made to listeners
that I have not fulfilled, which is your personal
examples for using money for experiences,
time, whatever comes to mind.
So we'll get to that.
But before that, death meditation.
Could you please describe your death meditation
and why you have a death meditation?
Arthur Brooks: Most people watching us are
not afraid of death, not pathologically afraid
of death.
Only about 20 percent of the population is
pathologically afraid of death.
And I bet you that it's less than one percent
of Tim Ferriss's followers because people
watching this are in control of their lives
and they understand the contours of their
lives and they're looking at the truth of
their lives, but they have a death fear.
The death fear isn't physical death, and this
is a problem.
For some people, it's irrelevance.
For some people, it's being forgotten.
For a lot of your listeners, it's failure,
just straight on failure because they're strivers,
they're achievers.
Everybody has a death fear.
And what is it?
It's an ego threat.
It's a threat to who you see as yourself.
If Tim Ferriss's Tim Ferrissness is threatened,
that will provoke a panic in you because that's
the ultimate death of who you see yourself.
The way to get over that — and by the way,
you have to get over that, we all have to
get over that, or we won't be fully alive
until we actually face the death that really
matters to us.
This is an insight that actually comes from
the Theravada Buddhist across the southern
tier of Asia, from Thailand and Myanmar to
Vietnam and parts of Malaysia and the Sri
Lanka in particular.
So the Theravada Buddhist monasteries, often
you'll go in and you'll see photos of cadavers
in different states of decomposition, super
macabre.
You're like, what are these dudes all about
here?
And what they do is that usually there will
be nine states of decomposition; photos, bodies
decomposing, falling apart, bones, bloated
corpses, and they stand in front of each one
and they say, that is me.
And then they move to the next one after contemplating
and saying, and that is me.
And what are they doing?
They're familiarizing themselves with the
truth of their future such that they can be
liberated from any fear of physical death.
Only then can they be fully alive.
That's an important insight from Theravada
Buddhism.
That's a meditation called Maranasati.
Tim Ferriss: Maranasati.
Arthur Brooks: The Maranasati death meditation.
Now, when I read that, I thought it was interesting,
but I thought it's a good thing to do because
I shouldn't be making all of these decisions
about when I'm old and when I'm retired and
when I die and what's going to happen and
call the lawyer and all that.
I want to be free from all that stuff by understanding
that life and death are in a very real way
an illusion, particularly because I believe
in eternal life, but I have a death fear.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah.
Arthur Brooks: You know what I'm afraid of?
You know my death fear?
Tim Ferriss: Who's going to take care of your
cats?
No, I don't know.
Arthur Brooks: That's good, man.
Who's going to take care of my dog, [Chu-cho].
Yeah.
It's losing my mind.
Tim Ferriss: On the way there.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah.
Because you know what Arthur Brooks is?
Gray matter.
Look, I'm not the smartest guy in the world,
I'm not the cleverest guy in the world, but
I make my living and I support my family,
and I understand me in terms of my ideas.
Literally, my company is called ACB Ideas,
right?
It was very revealing to me when I contemplated
the fact that I —
Tim Ferriss: Did you say ACB?
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, it's Arthur Charles Brooks.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, okay, it took me a second.
Arthur Brooks: I just can't remember the alphabet.
Little dyslexic.
It's like X, Z, Y. Anyway.
Tim Ferriss: I'm from Long Island.
Sorry, guys.
Arthur Brooks: Yes.
And my mother was showing signs of dementia
in her early fifties, and she was quite demented
by the time she was my age.
And it runs in families.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Arthur Brooks: It's genetic.
It doesn't mean I'm going to get the bullet.
I'm not being morbid about it, I'm not being
fatalistic about it.
Probably the odds are in my favor, but I'm
just terrified of that.
And when I recognized that, I realized I need
a Maranasati meditation on that.
And that's what I contemplate.
I'll take two minutes and I'll think my memory's
failing and I don't know why.
And then I imagine going to the neurologist,
the neurologist saying, well, I think you
need to come into my office.
And then I imagine myself telling my kids,
the future's going to be rough.
And then I imagine my work slipping away,
my inability to have this kind of conversation,
to write a book, to share an idea, to help
somebody with these ideas.
And then I imagine myself not remembering
what I don't remember.
And then I imagine being a beloved son of
God with no memory at all.
Now it's heavy, right?
Tim Ferriss: It seems like that ending point
is important.
Arthur Brooks: It's the most important because
you end on the truth.
Tim Ferriss: So if you're not religious, you
just end up to use the parlance of the kids
these days, just depressed AF.
Are you just —
Arthur Brooks: No.
Tim Ferriss: Shit out of luck?
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Arthur Brooks: Because in the end of the day,
in the Maranasati meditation, you recognize
the illusion of the tragedy that was your
death in the first place.
Ashes to ashes, dust to dust.
New life will emerge.
Will it be you?
Will it be somebody else?
Do you care?
See, when you look into the abyss, you can
cope with it.
You're stronger than that.
My students, by the way, at Harvard, graduate
students, Harvard Business School, best in
the world, so we like to think, they're afraid
of failure because they've never failed.
They've never failed.
You and I have struggled and we're older and
I've failed a lot, but my students are deeply
afraid of failure.
I basically got kicked out of college when
I was 19.
It turns out you're not supposed to drop all
your required classes and take nothing but
Indonesian dance and North Indian classical
drumming.
Turns out that's not the secret to academic
success.
Kids, make a note of it.
So I failed, right, but a lot of my students
haven't.
And so I asked them to do the Maranasati meditation
on their own academic and professional failure.
Number one, two minutes.
"I think I'm falling behind academically,
and the people around me are getting better
grades."
Two, "I just got put on academic probation.
This was my dream to come into this school
and I'm not succeeding."
Three, "The job mark is looking bad compared
to other people, I can't believe it."
Four, "I think I need to move home for a while."
Five, "My parents feel sorry for me."
That's when they cry, right?
Because all you want is for Mom to be proud
of you.
That's all you want when you're a success
addict, that's all you want.
And imagine that.
Look into that.
Stare into it.
And they do.
And they get over it and they can master it.
That's the Maranasati death meditation on
the self-objectification of the success addict.
Tim Ferriss: See, what do you see in those
students?
Because they come from all different backgrounds
and different orientations, religious or not,
or somewhere in between.
Arthur Brooks: Some are, some aren't.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
What types of effects and how frequently do
you personally do this type of death meditation?
Arthur Brooks: A lot.
Because I have my own death meditation.
I contemplate failure sometimes because I'm
afraid of it, but I'm not deathly afraid of
it.
The truth of the matter is the great thing
about being 46 as opposed to 26 for you, the
great thing about being 59 instead 29 for
me is that bad stuff is going to happen and
it's going to be okay.
Bad stuff's just going to happen, right?
The truth is that we realize, you and I both
realize that the worst thing that's ever happened
in life probably hasn't happened yet.
And okay, that's heavy, but it's not that
heavy.
We're going to survive.
You've survived a lot and it's actually going
to be okay.
I don't want to fail.
We have a book coming out.
I have a big book coming out a few weeks from
when we're taping this episode, and I deeply
wanted to be successful, but I can't control
that.
And so I don't have to do much more than a
couple of Maranasati meditations on the market
failure of a book.
But I have to do it about losing my mind because
that feels deeply existential to me.
I have to do it a lot.
I do it at least once a week actually, because
I want to remember.
I need to remember.
And if I don't, I'm going to be walking kind
of on eggshells and just sort of wondering
and having that kind of minor sense of dread.
I don't want to live that way.
I don't need to live that way.
It's not important for me to live that way.
On the contrary, it's important for me not
to live that way because I won't be fully
alive now.
I'll be living prospectively in a future,
and that future is dominated by fear.
And then I'm really not washing the dishes.
I'm really not enjoying that juicy peach.
On the contrary, I'm breaking my teeth on
the pit, and it's not even a real pit.
That's crazy.
Tim Ferriss: So —
Arthur Brooks: Not yet, really yet.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
This I think is a good tie-in to meaning,
and I'm going to get there with a self-indulgent
reference back to Marcus Aurelius.
For people who have not read Meditations.
Read Meditations.
It was never intended for publication.
These are effectively the pocket musings of
someone deeply conflicted, but also incredibly
impressive during war campaigns and otherwise.
But lots of thoughts on death.
And also for those interested, there's considered
Stoic practice that exists in a lot of different
varieties, but memento mori, there are these
meditations, premeditatio malorum.
Arthur Brooks: It's the Greek Maranasati,
for all intents and purposes, or Roman.
Tim Ferriss: Exactly.
He also thought very deeply on meaning.
Let's come to meaning.
So we identified two, I guess, of the legs
on the —
Arthur Brooks: Stool, right.
Tim Ferriss: Meaning.
How should we think about meaning?
Arthur Brooks: Meaning's the hard one.
Meaning's the hard one.
Look, enjoyment's no joke and satisfaction
takes work, but meaning eludes some people
their entire lives because they don't know
what they're looking for.
They're fumbling around for something.
They don't know exactly what it is.
And a lot of people, they deeply suspect that
it doesn't exist, that it doesn't actually
exist.
You look at a lot of 20th century and 19th
century philosophers and they say it doesn't
exist.
I mean, there's three schools of thought about
meaning.
There's the ancient Greeks and Romans and
the Christians and the Jews and the Muslims,
and it's all kind of based on meaning in the
following way.
Essence precedes existence.
Meaning, you have meaning in life that precedes
your actual life, and your job is to find
it and live up to it.
But it's already out there, you just need
to go looking for it.
In the 19th and 20th centuries, that was relaxed
with two major schools of philosophical thought,
Nihilism and Existentialism.
Existentialism, Sartre, and even to a certain
extent, Kierkegaard, would say that essence
precedes, no, that existence precedes essence.
In other words, you're born and there is no
meaning until you create it.
Tim Ferriss: Tabula rasa.
Good luck, kid.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, good luck.
Go make it.
If it's no good, it's on you, man.
By the way, Sartre, he has a very empowering,
a very muscular philosophy, because he says,
"You have to live up to the responsibility
of creating your essence and living according
to it."
It's sort of Freudian in its way.
And then, of course, there's Nietzsche, our
old pal Friedrich.
A lot of young men love Nietzsche, because
by the way, it's unbelievably beautiful prose,
a gorgeous writer, including in English.
You don't have to go learn German to read
it, but The Gay Science, which is one of his
most famous texts where he said, "God is dead
and we killed him."
It's just, it lands, right?
But his whole point is, existence is real,
but essence is a figment of your imagination.
So don't even try to find it.
That's Nihilism, right?
We're struggling with these schools of thought
and we all suspect it doesn't matter how religious
you are, it doesn't matter what your wiring
actually happens to be.
You kind of wonder if maybe Nietzche and Sartre
were right.
So you go in search of it and it turns out
"I want to go find the meaning of life" is
too big a question.
You'll never find it by sitting at the mouth
of the guru's cave or with the ayahuasca shaman
saying, "I just want to find meaning in life."
You need to boil it down to really sub-questions,
which are all about coherence.
"Why do things happen the way they do?
I need to believe something about why things
happen the way they do."
It doesn't mean religious.
It can be completely secular.
It might even be nihilistic.
You need to purpose, you need to answer a
purpose question, which is, "What's the purpose
of my life and what direction am I going?
What's the goal of my life?
What's the end point of my life?"
And the last is significance, which is why
does it matter that I'm alive?
Now I have a test to see if somebody has a
meaning crisis in their life.
That's really just two questions.
And to pass the test, you need incredibly
true, honest, and compelling answers.
There's no right answers.
There's only wrong answers or no answers.
So you want to take the test?
Tim Ferriss: Sure, why not?
Arthur Brooks: It’s go time.
Question number one.
This is, and again —
Tim Ferriss: This is to punish me for all
the ayahuasca I've done.
Go for it.
Arthur Brooks: I didn't say this just so you're
wrong with it.
I just think, what do we say?
It's necessary but not sufficient.
Tim Ferriss: Where’s my cat o' nine tails.
I had can opus Dei myself.
I left it back at the hotel.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Damn.
All right.
Arthur Brooks: Why are you alive?
Do you have an answer to the question of why
you're alive?
Tim Ferriss: I mean, I have a very clinical
answer for it.
Arthur Brooks: Tell me.
Well, I mean, there's the physical answer,
but metaphysically, why are you alive?
Which can be one of two things.
Either who created you or what you're put
on Earth to do.
You can answer that in one of two ways.
Do you have a strong belief in why you're
alive?
Tim Ferriss: I have a strong driver for taking
advantage of the fact that I am alive, but
I don't have a story of a creator or something
along those lines.
I don't.
Arthur Brooks: Or a strong purpose because
it can be a creator or a purpose.
Tim Ferriss: I do feel like I have a strong
purpose, but it doesn't relate to my birth.
Arthur Brooks: That's okay.
The why of your life.
Our mutual friend Simon Sinek talks about
this, start with why.
And the why of your life can be because of
a creation, or it can be because "I exist
to lift other people up and bring them together
in bonds of happiness and love," which by
the way is the why of my life.
So that's number one.
And if it's not, if it's there, but it's inchoate,
it's not quite clear enough, find out the
answer to that and write it down and then
perfect it over a six-month period.
Does that make sense.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I would say that for me,
I mean it's looking at and experiencing things
in unorthodox ways so that I can teach.
Yes.
Arthur Brooks: And why do you want to teach?
Tim Ferriss: Mostly to alleviate suffering,
I would say.
Arthur Brooks: In other words, you want to
lighten the load for other people.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Arthur Brooks: And so in other words, you
want to serve your sisters and brothers.
Is that fair?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, sure.
Arthur Brooks: Okay.
That's a great why.
That's a great answer to the first question:
"Why are you alive?"
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I don't feel conflicted
about that.
Arthur Brooks: Okay, so the second one's harder.
For what would you be willing to die today?
Tim Ferriss: I don't have a ready answer.
Arthur Brooks: It's a hard one.
It's a hard one.
A lot of people don't.
Tim Ferriss: What's your answer?
Arthur Brooks: For my faith, for my family,
for my country, and for you.
I am willing to die for others.
That's the answer.
I mean, I probably won't be called to it,
but I'm willing to do it.
I'm willing to do it.
I've come to the conclusion that I'm actually
willing to do it.
And here's how I learned this from my son.
I learned this actually from my son.
I mean, I have theoretical answers that are
politically correct in the Catholic sphere.
I would die for the Catholic Church.
I would die for my faith.
These things are true, by the way.
I really would.
But it's too pat.
Here's how I learned this from my son.
My son was, I have three kids, 25, 23, and
20.
And my middle son is named Carlos and Carlos
is, he's a kinetic boy.
He's a fan of yours.
He's probably watching us right now going,
"Oh.
My.
Oh, Dad's going to talk about me right now."
Sorry.
Tim Ferriss: Hey, Carlos.
Arthur Brooks: Sorry, Carlos.
And Carlos was having a good old time in high
school, and we had substantial grade problems
and academic issues.
And my wife's like, "At least we know he's
not cheating."
But the problem was he wasn't really having
fun, and I think it was a meaning problem.
And in search of the answers to the questions
after high school, he really became an entrepreneur
with his life.
And I asked my kids to do a business plan
when they're in high school because they're
entrepreneurs and I'm VC.
I'm an investor.
I deserve a business plan.
And when they weren't original, I'd send them
back for revisions.
,
Tim Ferriss: Bank of Dad?
Arthur Brooks: And it's really fun to be my
son.
You can imagine.
So Carlos's business plan for his life was
by the time it went through several rounds
of revisions, was appropriately unorthodox.
He was going to go work on a farm by himself
and find the answers to the questions, work
hard.
And so he actually got a job on a wheat farm
in Idaho, a real job, not some sort of hobby
farm.
No, no, no, no.
It was an 8,000-acre working wheat farm.
He lived in the farmer's basement for the
first year.
He picked rocks out of the soil.
He started in the bottom, made minimum wage,
fixed fences, cut down dead trees, ran a combine
by himself 16 hours a day.
Tim Ferriss: Why did he choose this?
How would he explain that?
Arthur Brooks: Because he needed to see what
he could do.
He needed to find out what it meant to be
Carlos Brooks, away from his family, away
from everybody.
Why?
Because he was looking for the answers to
the questions.
They were inchoate.
They were like, "Why am I alive?
I don't know.
Maybe I'll find it in the cab of a combine.
Maybe I'll find it when I dig rocks out of
the soil.
Maybe I'll find it by doing something hard
with my hands."
Then he joined the military.
He was 19 years old.
He joined the Marine Corps and bootcamp is
no walk in the park for the US Marine Corps
as we've all heard.
But then it got harder from there.
He did Infantry Training Battalion, and then
the End Dock for the Scout Sniper Platoon,
which is a branch of the Special Forces and
the Marines.
Today, he's Corporal Carlos Brooks, Marines
Three-Five Scout Sniper Platoon.
And he's got answers.
Now that's a scary job for me and his mom.
He goes on field trips, right?
Tim Ferriss: Field trips.
Arthur Brooks: And thank God nothing's happened
to him.
He's getting out of the military in December
of this year, but he's got answers.
Tim Ferriss: What types of answers?
I mean, I don't want you to —
Arthur Brooks: Here's his answers.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Arthur Brooks: I'll tell you his answers.
"Carlos, why are you alive?"
"Because God made me."
"For what are you willing to die?"
"For my faith and for my family and for my
friends, and for the United States of America."
Boom.
These are not the answers that a lot of people
watching us would give, but these are super
solid answers.
I'm super proud of my son because he earned
the answers to his meaning questions that
everybody watching us has got to earn it.
Everybody's watching us, everybody who's watching
us has got to go on a quest, a vision quest
for the answers to the meaning questions.
There's no other way to do it.
Your dad can't tell you.
Your priest can't tell you.
The holy books can give you inklings.
They can give you shadows on the cave wall,
to get back to the old Platonic metaphor.
You need to live and to try things and to
go through a process of discernment.
And the way to do that is to do hard things,
is to challenge yourself and to say to yourself,
I will not stop until I have answers to these
questions, to my own satisfaction.
Tim Ferriss: So hearing you describe Carlos's
experience, hi Carlos, and congratulations
on the trajectory.
Arthur Brooks: He's fine.
He's like, "Yeah, my dad embarrassed me, but
Tim Feriss just said hi to me on his podcast,
so it's all good."
Tim Ferriss: It is not easy.
I have some friends who are formerly Marine
force recon.
That is not —
Arthur Brooks: The recon guys are —
Tim Ferriss: That is not an easy path.
Arthur Brooks: No, it isn't.
Tim Ferriss: None of that is easy.
Yeah.
I think I was over processing the for what
would you be willing to die tomorrow?
I think it was the tomorrow piece that I fixated
on.
So family, close friends.
Arthur Brooks: You would die for your family.
You just would.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, family and close friends.
I can give that answer.
I was thinking of it more hypothetically as
a for what happening in the world would you
be willing to basically off yourself tomorrow.
Arthur Brooks: Is there an idea for which
you'd be willing to die?
Is there a truth?
Because this is really where it gets super
intense.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
That's where it gets intense.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah.
When Carlos says, "I am willing to die for
my faith, I am willing to die for the United
States of America," which for him is an ideal
of liberty.
By the way, for those of you outside of the
United States, he's willing to die for our
allies too.
Dying for an idea, that's super heavy.
I mean, that's like pure grade meaning, because
people are going to say, "Are you kidding
me?
Are you nuts?"
This is not, "I'm willing to kill for an idea."
That's kindergarten stuff.
No.
"I'm willing to die for something.
I'm willing to give my own life.
I'm willing to take yours.
You and every other half-baked, dark triad,
malignant narcissist, cancel-culture trait
psychopath."
Tim Ferriss: I thought you were talking to
me for a second.
I was like, "How did we get here all of a
sudden?
Arthur Brooks got really abusive on my podcast."
Arthur Brooks: No, no, no.
No, no.
Tim, I love you.
Tim Ferriss: Is this one of your high negative
moments?
Arthur Brooks: You're a beautiful man.
But I mean, come on.
I mean, everybody around the world is willing
to kill for what they think or cancel or hurt
people what they think.
But the real question is, are you willing
to sacrifice what you have for an idea?
And that's really hard.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I'm not sure.
That's a tough one for me to answer.
I think also thinking about what you're willing
to die for.
Let me personalize it.
Thinking about what I'm willing to die for.
I also want to be very aware if there are
things I would be willing to die for that
could be manipulated to make me do things
that I might not currently be morally aligned
with.
Arthur Brooks: Totally.
Totally.
For sure.
I get it.
Tim Ferriss: I think the allegiance —
Arthur Brooks: I get it.
Tim Ferriss: — it needs to be very, or for
me, I want to be aware if there are things.
For instance, faith has been manipulated by
politicians.
Arthur Brooks: So has patriotism.
Tim Ferriss: Of course.
Arthur Brooks: My goodness.
I mean, a lot of people listening say, "You'd
die for the United States of America.
Are you crazy?"
Tim Ferriss: Which is not to say that it's
wrong, it's just very context-dependent on
it.
Arthur Brooks: Very context-dependent, and
it requires a lot of updating and serious
thought, and it's not good enough to just
be sort of rah, rah, rah and taking it at
face value.
It takes serious discernment.
Tim Ferriss: So we have the why were you born
or for what —
Arthur Brooks: Why are you alive?
Tim Ferriss: — are you alive.
What would you be willing to die for?
Arthur Brooks: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Got any more?
Arthur Brooks: Those are the ones.
I mean, what those do is that they really
kind of wrap up coherence, purpose, and significance
into two kind of handy dandy questions.
And the point is really this, I mean, it's
easy for me to frame that up is once you find
those, you're all good to go.
All right.
But the truth is, you're going to go through
the rest of your life contemplating these
things, and these are the questions to ask
on your birthday.
"Are these still the things that I believe?
Have I updated my knowledge?
Do I have a better sense of who I am?
Have I gone backwards a little bit?
Have I lost this sense of what I'm willing
to die for?
Do I need to go a little deeper at this point?"
And touching up on those questions turns out
to be a really good, it's sort of the same
thing when you go to the doctor and they do
the same test again and again and again and
again.
I have a series of tests that I do or these
questions that I ask myself like that about
the reverse bucket list and the meaning questions.
And am I pursuing my pleasures socially and
making memory with my prefrontal cortex?
I also have, by the way, a spreadsheet of
19 micronutrients that feed into my macronutrients.
And I grade myself on tenths of one percent
on a one to 10 scale weighted with respect
to what my best estimate of my well-being.
And when I'm going backwards on those things,
I set a strategic plan for my year.
So I know I'm getting crazier by the minute,
right?
Tim Ferriss: I'm into it.
I encourage it.
I want to pour gasoline on the fire.
Arthur Brooks: Let's do it, man.
Tim Ferriss: So we already talked about death
meditation.
We talked about your experience in Mexico,
and I think in Build the Life You Want, obviously
we're not going to go into all the micronutrients
of each of the legs on the stool per se, but
I'm curious whether it's meaning or one of
the others.
Maybe meaning, but it doesn't have to be.
Could you give some examples of some of those,
I don't want to say antecedents, but micronutrients,
the cast of characters and ingredients that
are important for sort of healthy functioning?
Arthur Brooks: For sure.
For sure.
And you can break them up in as variegated
a way as you want.
You can make 20,000 of them, but really there's
four that we should be thinking about.
So there's four fundamental micronutrients,
and I make it more varied than that.
I've got 19 because they're really about love
and relationships.
That's really what it's all about.
And the big four are your search for the divine
or your spiritual journey or your philosophical,
your faith, whatever that happens to be.
Religious or not.
It's your love for something bigger than you
so you can stand in awe.
It's your family relationships.
These are the most mystical kinds of love
that we get because we didn't choose the loves.
They were chosen for us.
And sometimes we're like, yeah, I wouldn't
have chosen that.
Friendship, and friendship when I'm talking
about that, I talk a lot about loneliness
because especially strivers, hardworking people,
a lot of people watching us, they have a lot
of people around them, but what they have
is deal friends, but not real friends.
And your deal friends are super useful to
you.
Your real friends are useless, cosmically,
beautifully useless.
And so I go into a lot of detail with my students
about how to build useless friendships, not
worthless.
That's different.
I've got those too.
And last but not least, it's loving everybody's
expressed through your work, and that means
serving others with your work.
Your work should be a service profession no
matter what you're doing.
And so faith, family, friends, and work.
And then there's, we branch out from there.
And I'm talking about family.
I'm talking about different branches of family
that I'm trying to make sure I'm working on
when I'm talking about.
My marriage is critically important.
It gets one of the absolute highest scores
in importance.
Not always in terms of quality because I'm
not the best husband, but in terms of importance
for sure.
And that's because that's the apex of two
of those columns, both family and friendship.
My best friend and also the adopted member
of my family is my wife.
And so therefore, my marriage is really at
the top of those two pillars.
And so I'm thinking about that a lot.
So I break it up into subcategories, but they
all go into those silos of faith, family,
friends, and work.
Work that serves, work that's meaningful,
earn my success.
And then I say, "Okay, well, what does it
mean to earn my success?
What does it mean to serve others?
How do I know?"
Et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
And I start getting down to brass tacks.
I start putting numbers on it.
And if the numbers aren't, if I'm going backwards
in a particular year — I do it.
My birthday and my off birthday, by the way.
Tim Ferriss: Your off birthday?
Arthur Brooks: Yeah.
Yeah.
My six-month birthday, November 21st.
Tim Ferriss: Got it.
Arthur Brooks: My birthday's May 21st, so
November 21st.
Tim Ferriss: That's convenient that you got
Thanksgiving week.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, I've got Thanksgiving
week.
And so it gives me a chance to actually think
about these things in some detail to be sure.
And then I've got the data going back to about
the year 1999.
I've got it going forward.
And this system has gotten better along the
way and changed.
Tim Ferriss: What are the most important changes
you've made to the system, would you say?
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, the most important change,
the single most important change I made to
the system was the recognition that I knew
a lot about happiness, but wasn't happy because
I was studying it, but I wasn't doing it.
The biggest change to the system was using
my knowledge to change my habits.
That was number one, far and away.
It's one thing I was giving people all this
advice about friendships and about having
a good marriage and all that.
I was looking at my life and I wasn't living
these things.
I was just like everybody else, waking up,
going, sure hope I feel happy today.
It was pathetic.
It was like a drug and alcohol counselor getting
up and taking a bunch of bong hits and having
a six-pack.
That's what it was.
It was craziness.
And by the way, it was my wife who finally
clued me.
She's like, "You have a PhD, right?
What are you using it for?"
Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: And you're like, "Your English
has come a long way."
Arthur Brooks: "You're killing me, sweetheart.
You're killing me."
But I'm writing academic journal articles
that 14 people read so I can get promotion
and tenure.
It was ridiculous.
Tim Ferriss: So how did you, I imagine even
if you're not necessarily walking the walk
as much as you would you like, you believe
in what you are sharing.
So it wasn't necessarily a conviction issue.
So how do you then translate it to action?
Are you just like, "You know what?
If it's not in the calendar, it's not real.
Let me commit to things that I block out so
that they are unavoidable in a sense."
How did you convert it?
Arthur Brooks: Well, I started by doing habits
and practices that were very, very specific.
I mean extremely specific, as specific as
the stuff in The 4-Hour Body specific.
And I was writing stuff down.
I held whole notebooks of protocols and things
that I was trying.
I was trying things on myself based on science.
And when it worked, I would keep it and I
would write it down.
I would practice it.
Turns out that wasn't good enough because
it's very easy to have, because that was too
hacky.
That wasn't really habits.
To ingrain a habit, you've got to do one more
step, which is that you've got to teach it.
The reason I'm a happiness professor is because
I want to lash myself to the mast, and I want
to be completely committed.
Because look, I mean, if I'm doing something
that's clearly at odds with what I'm teaching,
I'm going to hear about it.
I'm going to hear about it from my students.
I'm going to hear about it from my family.
I'm going to hear about it.
Good lord, I'm going to hear about it on social
media, not that I'm paying that much attention
to that because I want to be happy and it's
really, really important.
So basically, there's a protocol in my life,
which is number one, understand, number two,
practice, number three, share.
And that's the protocol that works for everybody
when it comes to happiness.
You've got to take those three steps.
You've got to do the work and understand.
It's funny because I've done all this work
over the years with the Dalai Lama, and he
always says the same thing.
"If you want to be a spiritual adept, think
more, feel less, think more, feel less."
Tim Ferriss: I would not expect.
Arthur Brooks: No.
Right?
Tim Ferriss: That to be the framing.
Okay.
What does he mean by that?
Arthur Brooks: Well, he first wakes up in
the morning, in the first two hours of his
meditation, he gets up at three or 3:30 in
the morning.
The first thing that he does after a little
bit on his exercise bike and hanging out with
his cat, the first thing that he does is two
hours of analytical meditation, which Catholics
call mental prayer.
That means you take a couple of lines of sacred
scripture and you analyze it and you think
about it.
Most learning doesn't happen when the professor
talks about something.
If you understand everything the professor
says, it's not a hard enough class, and you
don't have a very good professor.
He has to blow your mind with something, and
you've got to go away and think about it.
And then you learn it through your own thinking.
That's analytical meditation, or mental prayer.
Tim Ferriss: And is the Dalai Lama using scripture
in this sense, or what?
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, Tibetan Buddhist scripture.
So he's contemplating something, words of
the Buddha or Śāntideva or any of the ancients.
Tim Ferriss: Tactical questions.
Is he choosing it or is it flip open the book,
which would not denigrate it.
I'm just wondering?
Arthur Brooks: Drop the needle.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I mean —
Arthur Brooks: No, it's extraordinary.
I mean, the holy scriptures for Tibetan Buddhists
are vast.
There's a library in Dharamshala that's just
stack after stack, after stack after stack.
It's not a Bible.
It's not like a collection of books in a little
library called the Bible.
It's enormous.
And the monks are going through the scriptures
again and again and again.
So I'm sure he hasn't explained it to me,
but I'm sure that he has actually a regular
rotation that he's going through to do his.
And that's what we need to do.
Tim Ferriss: He's got the equivalent of these
10 exercises when you go to the gym, skip
the bench press, like he's got his —
Arthur Brooks: Yeah.
Kind of.
Tim Ferriss: — his greatest hits.
Arthur Brooks: No doubt.
Yeah, no doubt.
And that's really important to do in the science
of happiness, is to look at what the best
protocols, what does it mean to stand up to
your negativity bias by actually practicing
gratitude when what you're feeling is resentment.
How do you do that?
How do you actually achieve a state of metacognition
awareness of your own feelings such that you
can choose reactions in the face of emotions?
How can you get into the state of the I self,
which is the state in which you're observing
the world as opposed to observing yourself?
Well, it starts with knowledge of what these
concepts are, and then you put it into practices,
real exercises.
I have a column in The Atlantic that comes
out every Thursday morning.
Tim Ferriss: That's next on my list of questions.
Arthur Brooks: The third part of every column
is do these three things, is taking the science
and then applying to your life in these three
ways.
And so it's application and change of habits
and a commitment to that and the best way
to cement in those ideas and by lashing yourself
to the mast.
And that's by teaching these things to everybody
else.
And everybody, look, I have a lab at Harvard
called the Leadership and Happiness Lab.
The whole point of the lab is not bench science
and pouring stuff into test tubes or doing
new experiments.
It's learning how we can all be happiness
teachers.
How can Tim Feriss be a happiness teacher?
You already are, by the way.
Tim Ferriss: Working on it.
I'm working on it.
Arthur Brooks: Well, you're working on it.
And there's no reason that you have to be
happy to be a happiness teacher.
It's not like playing basketball.
Tim Ferriss: Thank God.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, totally.
I mean, on the contrary, the people are struggling
the best at it.
Tim Ferriss: I'm not as miserable as some.
Arthur Brooks: You're fine.
Tim Ferriss: Pretending to be.
Arthur Brooks: I mean, the point is that you're
—
Tim Ferriss: But I do have struggles.
I mean, I do have challenges otherwise.
Arthur Brooks: Course you do.
So do I. You're self-aware.
You're self-aware.
And part of your commitment, because I know
your work, part of your commitment to lifting
other people up is sharing your journey.
This is what it comes down to.
So you joke about, ah, but the truth of the
matter is we're all ugh.
We all are.
And sharing that is actually part of the way
that you're practicing these protocols.
You're not hacking anything.
You're actually trying to build these habits.
And then the teaching role, you're a teacher,
by the way, because this is a teaching podcast.
We're not shooting the breeze and saying,
"What'd you see on TV?
And I went to a new restaurant."
No, we're talking about heavy stuff because
we actually want to teach these ideas and
lift other people up.
So that's the secret, man.
Learn more, think more.
Don't feel.
Learn, think.
Second, turn this into habits and practice
this as habits.
Third, share with others and commit to other
people through your teaching.
That's the secret of happiness.
Tim Ferriss: Commit.
Commit in what sense?
Just energetically taking the magnifying glass
off of yourself?
Arthur Brooks: Committing to actually these
practices in your own life.
And this can often be, "I've been doing this
thing wrong and I don't want to keep doing
this thing wrong.
And me telling you it's making yourself accountable
to another person."
All 12-step programs work this way, right?
Tim Ferriss: Honestly, 12-step programs, AA,
some of the most important and impressive
decentralized organizations I've ever seen,
and I've never participated, but I am so impressed.
Arthur Brooks: But they require accountability
because basically what 12-step programs do
is knowledge of what's wrong with me, committing
to new habits, and sharing it with others.
That's why AA works is because of those three
steps as well.
Tim Ferriss: They do sneak some God in there.
Arthur Brooks: Well, yeah, the higher power
for sure.
The higher power.
Tim Ferriss: Which is helpful.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I'm not going to deny it.
One facet that I really appreciate of your
work and your writing is that you straddle
the very old and the very new, and you mentioned
Aquinas earlier.
Again, everybody read a few pages, at least
on Wikipedia, about Aquinas and then Aristotle.
And one of your popular columns is about Aristotle's
10 secrets to happiness.
I wonder if any, I do have them in front of
me.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, because I can't remember
them.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I was just going to say,
this is a lot to remember.
Arthur Brooks: The problem of making a weekly
copy.
Tim Ferriss: Well, how about this?
How about I read through and then I would
love for you to pick out one or two perhaps
that have been particularly impacted for you
or for your readers.
Arthur Brooks: Right.
Tim Ferriss: Here we go.
Name your fears and face them.
Two, know your appetites and control them.
Three, be neither a cheapskate nor a spendthrift.
Four, give as generously as you can.
Five, focus more on the transcendent.
Disregard the trivial.
Six, true strength is a controlled temper.
Seven, never lie, especially to yourself.
Eight, stop struggling for your fair share.
Nine, forgive others and forbear their weaknesses.
10, define your morality.
Live up to it, even in private.
And I want to take one off the table.
Arthur Brooks: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: Which is the last one because
there's a recency bias here since we've been
talking, I think fairly extensively about
that.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah.
Those are, here we go.
So let's start with number seven.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
Arthur Brooks: Never lie, be impeccable with
your word, especially with you.
Now, I know a lot of people who are pretty
honest.
Frankly, the reason my wife fell in love with
me is not my stunning good looks and my lousy
accent.
Tim Ferriss: And the great hair at the time.
Arthur Brooks: Gray hair?
Tim Ferriss: No, great hair.
Arthur Brooks: Great hair.
I know.
I mean, it was spectacular if I do say so
myself.
But the reason she told me later is because
I was the first man that never lied to her.
I never lied.
Now, that's part of my upbringing, and that
has to do with your family, et cetera.
That was a really super important value in
my home.
You had to be honest.
The only really dramatic and scary consequences
with my parents were from lying.
Don't lie, don't lie, don't lie.
And so the result is, it was kind of in a
way easier for me because of the way that
I was raised, but I was the first guy she'd
ever met that didn't lie.
She's like, "What's up with this dude?
He doesn't lie."
And I've procured when my oldest son, both
of my sons 25 and 23, they're both married.
And when my 25-year-old —
Tim Ferriss: 25 and 23, both married.
Arthur Brooks: They're both married.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
I need to get relationship advice from your
son.
Arthur Brooks: Well, my older son, he's a
piece of work.
I mean, I learned a lot from him.
He's literally one of the brightest native
intelligence people that I've ever met.
But he also has this super adroit moral instinct
to him.
And he asked me, he said, "Tell me one thing
that I should never do because I'm in love
with this girl, that I should never do."
He asks good questions like that.
And I thought about it.
I said, "It's actually pretty easy.
Never lie to her ever, ever, ever, ever, ever.
Until you go to the grave, never lie to her
and ask her never to lie to you.
No matter what the consequences."
Now, that's the secret to the pure oxygen
of a true companionate love, the mystical
love of the romance where you feel truly chosen
for each other.
It has to be based on honesty.
It has to be.
And a lot of people are like, yeah, yeah,
good luck with that.
And there are lots of things.
That doesn't mean you have to say, by the
way, "Sweetheart, your butt looks fat in that."
Tim Ferriss: I was just going to ask.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah.
No, no, no.
It doesn't mean you have to volunteer every
single thing that you're thinking because
you're not insane.
But when there's a direct question, there's
a direct answer.
What I comes down to.
Okay, that's fine.
But that's, you say in Spanish, "That's [foreign
language]."
That's okay.
Tim Ferriss: Table stakes.
Arthur Brooks: Table stakes, man.
You want to really be in the game, never lie
to yourself.
And we're doing it all the time.
We're doing it all the time.
We don't want to face up to the truth.
We don't want to look really in the mirror
and not so that we can think how great our
hair looks or whatever, but so that we can
actually see the good and the bad.
And to say, I'm a true human being.
That's a hard thing to do when people lie
to themselves constantly.
And Aristotle talked about that, and Aquinas
and the Buddha, and one of the things that
they all have in common is that they have
this impeccable idea of self-honesty, which
is that's taking a draft of the purest liquor
of life.
It's like, yeah, I can drink that.
I'm going to drink that.
Really?
You tough enough to drink that?
And once you start doing that, I mean, it's
hard.
It's really hard, but it's life changing.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
So I have a question about that, and it also
makes me think about some of the scientists
I respect most, like Richard Feynman who says,
"You must not fool yourself, and you're the
easiest person to fool."
Arthur Brooks: Well, for sure.
And a lot of people say, because I'm religious,
that I'm fooling myself.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Well, this leads not to a religion-specific
question, but rather just to a fine slicing,
which is sometimes, and I'm going off the
cuff, so this isn't going to be polished,
but we lie to ourselves in the sense that
we have a story about ourselves or the world
that we know isn't quite true, but we repeat
it enough because we want it to be true.
Then there are times when we lie to ourselves,
but we are in the delusion.
It is because we have a lack of awareness
or who knows, there are any number of factors
that have fed into this belief, which is simply
not accurate, for whatever reason.
So how do you catch yourself?
Could you give examples, hypothetical or otherwise
of, because I think most people would say,
"I don't want to lie to myself."
But when it comes down to actually catching
those, catching those self-lies, that self-deception
in the butterfly net, so you can do something
with them, how do you do that?
Arthur Brooks: Well, you commit yourself to
being uncomfortable, for one thing.
So there's a couple of different ways to do
that.
Number one is you seek outside counsel.
You ask people who really know you well.
You ask them to be committed to telling you
the absolute truth, and then you ask them
incredibly hard questions about yourself,
and you should have friends that can do that
for you.
This is one of the ways that you can do it,
but your friends really have to be able to
tell you the truth.
Most, being a good friend usually means telling
you convenient lies.
That's not the right criterion for your closest
friends, your real friends.
Your real friends, who should be like, "Buddy,
I don't think you're being straightforward
with that right now."
See, this is, I'm doing a fake Atlanta accent
because my best friend's a guy named Frank,
and he lives in Atlanta, and we are committed
to telling each other the truth.
And boy, does he ever give it to me, both
barrels, when he thinks I'm being full of
it.
"Buddy, I don't know.
I don't know.
I know you're saying that thing, but let's
drill down on that a little bit, shall we?"
I talk to him every week.
That's super important.
Tim Ferriss: Every week.
Arthur Brooks: Sure.
"Can I talk to you?" because he's a real friend
and that takes work.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
No, I understand.
But is that like you have a standing?
Arthur Brooks: No, it's not.
No.
But he's somebody where we're committed to
when the call comes in and says "Frank," I'd
take the call.
Even if it's during work time, I take the
call.
But otherwise, you can't take every single
call that comes in.
There are certain colleagues, certain family
members, and Frank.
Tim Ferriss: And have you guys explicitly
made some type of mutual commitment?
And the reason I ask is there are environments
also that I suppose I could join, but I haven't
up to this point.
For instance, YPO forums, these small groups.
Arthur Brooks: Those are quite good.
Tim Ferriss: They are very good.
Arthur Brooks: Six, seven, eight guys.
Tim Ferriss: And I know people who have benefited
from it tremendously.
And there, as I understand it, based on my
friend's stories, there are many hot seat
moments where you get your beliefs and stories
and approaches and strategies interrogated.
Arthur Brooks: And you are committed in a
YPO forum to have your BS called out.
Tim Ferriss: Yep.
Arthur Brooks: So if you're saying something
they know is not true about you —
Tim Ferriss: There's some great rules.
People can study it also, if you wanted to
try to mimic or replicate it.
I guess for a lot of folks, and I hate to
say it, but I think especially men, they may
not have sort of a codified setting like that.
Arthur Brooks: Especially successful men tend
to get lonelier and lonelier as they get older.
Women tend to get less and less lonely, but
men tend to get lonelier and lonelier.
So about 60 percent of 60-year-old men say
their best friend is their wife.
About 30 percent of their wives say their
best friend is their husband.
Tim Ferriss: No.
Arthur Brooks: This is the story of, sad story
of unrequited friendship, unrequited companion
love at home, for sure.
But you know what that means is that a lot
of women have very, very close friends that
they've cultivated, usually through family
life and community life, and guys, it's like,
"Hey, man, I worked so hard over the years
and hanging out with my friends is stealing
from my family.
I'm not going to go golfing for five hours
on Saturday.
When the kids are little, it'll be terrible
at home.
I'll get yelled at and yada, yada, yada yada,"
all kinds of excuses, and pretty soon they're
lonely.
Tim Ferriss: And we might come back to this,
I mean, the loneliness is a big topic and
the bonding and these types of communal relationships.
But as far as cultivating a relationship with
the friends that you have, that unvarnished
feedback and interrogation, is there a suggestion?
Might you have any suggestion for how to approach
that?
Arthur Brooks: Well, there's two ways to do
it.
There's the organic way and there's the manual
way.
The organic way is that you don't lose those
true friends that you've had, usually since
you were a young adult.
And a lot of people do.
I mean, we move around a lot and we're really
ambitious and our friends wind up being our
deal friends.
And our real friends, people will say — I
mean, I'll do an exercise where I'll say,
"Tell me the 10 people that are closest to
you.
Write them down real quick."
Tim Ferriss: I can do it easily.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I literally have it in a spreadsheet.
Arthur Brooks: That's great.
And then put real or deal after each one of
those names based on the fact that — and
for you, it's all real, right?
Because you have close friends, right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I do.
A high percentage from a long time ago.
Arthur Brooks: And you travel with them and
you do stuff with them, right?
Tim Ferriss: I put a lot of energy and time
into ensuring that we spend time together,
which gets harder as people have wives and
kids and everything else.
Arthur Brooks: And children, for sure.
Family life tends to get in the way of that.
But it's like anything else, you've got to
do the work.
Tim Ferriss: I'm unfettered by my direct family
life.
Arthur Brooks: But the data say that in 10
years you'll most likely be married and have
kids and it's going to be harder.
But you'll have to put in —
Tim Ferriss: Inshallah!
Arthur Brooks: Folks, let's work on this.
Shall we?
Write in the comments your best —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah.
All right.
So there's the organic way.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, there's organic way,
which is make sure that you don't lose track
of your real friends and you have a commitment
with your real friends to hold you to a standard
of honesty in the friendship and with yourself,
because that's what true friendship really
entails.
The manual way is the YPO forum way where
there's a bunch of guys that you know that
are usually deal friends and you make a deal
to make them into real friends.
You make a deal.
It's like an arrangement where part of the
friendship is actually going to be to go deeper,
to hold each other's secrets, to be honest
with each other.
And that can actually be incredibly effective
because you've actually decided to do that
and people will owe up to those particular
promises.
Psychological safety is really important in
that too, because it's one thing to say, "I
want you to be completely honest with me,"
and say, "Yeah, you're a jerk."
It's like not that honest, or don't express
it in that particular way.
You have to have enough psychological safety
where the rules of the road are clear that
honesty is always wielded as a gift and never
as a weapon.
That's also true in marriages, by the way,
Tim.
The best marriages are completely honest,
but the honesty is a gift and never a weapon.
Tim Ferriss: Yep.
One of the mantras at Facebook before it was
Meta was "Feedback is a gift.
Feedback is a gift.
Feedback is a gift."
It was repeated over and over again.
It was put all over the place to cultivate
a culture of feedback.
And I've thought about that, just grabbing
these little snippets.
"Make yourself small."
I mean these very pithy reminders that will
have some stickiness in the mind and also
doubling down on having your friends act as
the best mirrors available.
Very brief side note, just to give people
a Scooby snack, mirrors, reflections.
What are your thoughts?
Arthur Brooks: Get rid of them.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, tell me more.
Arthur Brooks: So I work with a guy, he's
fantastic.
He actually is.
He's really, really helpful for me.
I've recommended him to you because he does
incredible body work.
Physical therapy is fantastic, and he was
a fitness model.
There's almost nothing you can do that's unhealthier,
worse for your mental health, than being a
fitness model or fitness influencer.
Tim Ferriss: Why?
Arthur Brooks: Because you're just looking
in the mirror all day long and your physical
appearance is that on which you'll be judged
is very emotionally warping.
And he hated it.
He hated it.
He was unhappy.
He never ate what he wanted for 10 years.
And the truth of the matter is, as we all
know, you look great if your body fat is under
10 percent, but you feel crummy and you want
everybody in the world to die.
It can be really, really hard on you.
And he said, but after a while, there's a
reason that 35 percent of people who lose
a lot of weight, when they get to their goal,
they keep going and a quarter of them develop
an eating disorder.
The reason is because you can't stop when
you're looking in the mirror all the time.
You can't stop.
You don't know how to stop.
So he had the presence of mind.
He's an adept, he's a spiritual adept.
He got rid of all of his mirrors and showered
in the dark for a year.
He got rid of all of the mirrors in his house.
Tim Ferriss: The showering in the dark, I
need — maybe I —
Arthur Brooks: Well, because you can't see
your abs.
Tim Ferriss: I don't have that problem, but
yeah, I get it.
You've got washboard abs and you're looking
at you going, "Yeah, man.
Yeah, yeah."
And bye-bye watching the water cascade off
your 12-pack like rocks in a waterfall.
Arthur Brooks: I know, and the truth of the
matter is that —
Tim Ferriss: I hate when that happens.
Arthur Brooks: Extreme —
Tim Ferriss: But yes, I get it.
Arthur Brooks: — physical attractiveness
ordinarily is something that you do because
you want to become more lovable and you make
that judgment on the basis of what you're
seeing in the mirror and not the relationship
that you're projecting to others in real life.
It's really weird.
You talk to dudes who are trying to get to
six percent body fat and get super jacked
and the whole thing, and they have this — they
imagine that women are going to be just super
attracted to them, and the only people who
even say anything are dudes.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, it's always dudes.
It's like I have friends who're single guys
and they have incredible beard game or mustache
game and nonstop it's just dudes coming up
and complimenting them.
I mean, I'm sure there are women who like
it too, but it's mostly guys.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, for sure.
Tim Ferriss: It seems to be similar.
Arthur Brooks: No woman has ever said, "Nice
car."
I mean, it's just, no, it's other guys is
the whole thing.
And what that is the other guys are just a
mirror.
They're just a mirror.
The other guys are saying the thing that you
think, but it's profoundly unsatisfying if
you're actually in the heterosexual dating
market to have other guys saying, "God, how’d
you get those abs?"
Tim Ferriss: Who cares?
Now to provide a counter example also, and
this is just something I've seen on dating
apps that we could talk about, but I have
yet to meet a single guy I like and respect
who's like, "I love super intense lip fillers
and all of this Frankenbotox situation."
I have not met a single one yet.
Arthur Brooks: I know.
And have you ever said — I've never said
to my wife one time, "That's such a cute little
dress.
Is it new?"
I've never said that.
All her friends say that, and she's always
like, "I have a cute little dress, and everybody
noticed it, but you didn't."
Tim Ferriss: For the record, I'm into cute
little dresses.
I don't want people to mix up voices here.
Arthur Brooks: The show notes just went "BRRRRR!"
Tim Ferriss: So why did you write this book
and how did it come to be?
I know you have this long history with thinking
about these catalyzing events and tracking,
and I don't want to say pursuing, but analyzing,
thinking deeply about happiness.
So why now and what do you hope that it will
accomplish?
Arthur Brooks: So this new book is the most
bread and butter book I've ever written about
the science of happiness.
It's two parts.
Part one is how to manage your emotions so
they don't manage you.
Part two is once you've got that down, now
you can actually build your life and not be
distracted and frittering away your time with
stupid things.
Those are the two parts of the book, and it's
as deep a dive as I've ever actually written
publicly about neuroscience.
It was actually vetted by my colleague at
Harvard, Josh Greene, who's one of the most
distinguished neuroscientists in the world,
just to make sure, because I'm a social scientist,
so I've got to be careful getting into the
biology side of this thing.
I know enough to be dangerous to be sure,
but I have to be very careful about that.
And by the way, this project was instigated
to do a bread and butter owner's manual on
you and your happiness.
That's what it is.
It's an owner's manual on your happiness.
It wasn't my idea, it was Oprah Winfrey's
idea.
Tim Ferriss: So you occupy some rarefied air.
So from the Dalai Lama, you just bump into
her on the subway?
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, Her holiness Dalai Lama.
I mean, His Holiness Dalai Lama and Her Holiness
Oprah Winfrey, right?
Tim Ferriss: Yes, exactly.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah.
I mean, when Oprah Winfrey calls, it's like
—
Tim Ferriss: Right.
But I'm guessing she didn't get your phone
number on Zoom info.
How did this happen?
Arthur Brooks: She calls, I'm like, "Yeah,
I'm Batman.
No, really?
Who is this?"
No.
Tim Ferriss: "Hi, it's Oprah calling again.
Your company has been verified by Dunn and
Bradstreet."
Oh, wait a minute.
Anyway —
Arthur Brooks: So we got connected because
she is a regular reader of my column in The
Atlantic, and she was during the coronavirus
epidemic when people were trying to use the
time to learn new things, et cetera.
And she was actually a serious reader of the
column.
And she's a serious reader.
Tim Ferriss: She's a serious reader.
Arthur Brooks: When she has a book on her
podcast, she reads the book.
It's just amazing how exhaustive her knowledge
is.
And then when my book came out, From Strength
to Strength in February 2022, she got it literally
in the first week, she read it, and that's
when she called and she said, "Would you come
on my podcast?"
Her Super Soul, which is this book podcast,
phenomenal.
And we were like a house on fire from the
very beginning because she's — it's funny
because you've met a lot of famous people
and I've met some famous people, and they're
usually not exactly like they appear in public.
She's like she appears in public.
I mean, she's calm, she's smart, she's nice,
she's funny, she's awesome.
She's actually what people think she is.
She's truly an authentic person.
And so we really got along and we have the
synchronicity of mission, which is to lift
people up and bring them together in bonds
of happiness and love, but we have different
platforms for doing it.
I'm teaching this class on the science of
happiness at Harvard University and writing
in The Atlantic.
She has been in mass media forever, and whenever
she weighs in, she has millions and millions
and millions of people around the world that
trust her and want to hear what she has to
say.
And so her suggestion was, "Let's take that
class that you teach at Harvard and that you're
writing about in The Atlantic, let's present
that to a big audience.
You want a big audience?"
I said, "Yeah.
Yes, yes, yes.
Oprah, can I have a big audience, please?"
And she says, "Let's write a book together
and we'll present this book together."
And so we did, and we got together at her
home and we framed it up.
We framed up the book over a three- or four-day
period last year in her teahouse in Montecito,
California.
And I was looking around going, I'm just like
this small town college professor who fell
off the turnip truck in front of Oprah's teahouse.
You never know.
He's like, God bless America.
You never know what's going to happen.
And it was super fun.
It was super interesting.
Tim Ferriss: It's the best country for people
who want to work hard.
Arthur Brooks: Oh, my goodness.
Oh, my goodness.
And she's the best case study in American
success and working hard and believing in
others and paying it forward possible.
And then we went and we started working on
our respective parts of the book and passing
it back and forth.
And I took a house in San Clemente in California
for six weeks in the winter largely to look
at the Pacific Ocean to write the book, and
she was writing her parts.
And then we got to this impasse at one point,
not between us, but because the title didn't
fit.
The title now is How to Build the Life You
Want: The Art and Science of Getting Happier.
And it was called Fully Alive and it wasn't
fitting, and I didn't know.
And finally Oprah calls me and she says, "Got
the wrong title."
Tim Ferriss: She's a genius.
Arthur Brooks: "We've got the wrong title.
This is a how to book.
This is an owner's manual book.
This is really a how to book on your own happiness.
This should be called How to Build a Life
You Want."
And ching, the whole thing fell into place.
Because that's what happens as you know, in
the course of writing a book, you think you
have it, but you don't.
And then when the title actually completes
the book and allows you to finish the book
and make it all cohere.
Then we finished it up and it was this amazing
collaborative experience, a joy, actually,
it was the most fun.
It was the most positive experience I've ever
had writing a book because I got to write
it with her, and she's enriched my life.
Tim Ferriss: What a wild, incredible experience.
Arthur Brooks: It's nuts.
It's nuts, man.
I told you my death fear is losing my mind.
It's actually possible that I am and that's
just a hallucination.
Tim Ferriss: "So then we had tea, and we had
crumpets, and we played bridge."
Arthur Brooks: Had tea in her teahouse and
all that.
It's like, "But Tim, I know I want the pure
truth.
But if that's not true, don't tell me."
Tim Ferriss: "Let me keep that one.
Let me keep one."
Arthur Brooks: "Lie to me, baby."
Tim Ferriss: So in this book, are there areas
— because I know in my book I can point
to specific chapters where I'm like, "Man,
I really wish people had paid more attention
to X."
Maybe it didn't quite get the emphasis so
I can own that responsibility, but maybe they,
for whatever reason, didn't pay enough attention
to this one component.
Is there something that comes to mind?
Arthur Brooks: I don't know yet 'cause it
hasn't come out.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I know, but I'm just saying
—
Arthur Brooks: So what do I suspect?
Tim Ferriss: What would hurt you the most
if people missed?
Arthur Brooks: I think what would bother me
the most is the amount that Oprah and I emphasize
the role of unhappiness in living a full life.
See, one of the biggest mistakes that people
make as we talked about before, is that people
say, "I want to be happy, but..."
And then they talk about some source of unhappiness
in their life that they think blocks their
happiness.
And that's the wrong way of thinking because
you can get happier even if you're unhappy,
absolutely 100 percent all day long, because
these are existing in different parts of your
brain, number one.
But number two, happiness is not the goal
and unhappiness is not the enemy.
Getting happier is the goal.
Oprah coined this term in the book.
She said, "We've got to stop talking about
happiness because that's actually not the
goal.
The goal is happierness."
That's really what we're going for is happierness.
And to get happierness, you need unhappiness
in your life.
Look, you need negative emotions to keep you
alive, but you also need the deferral of gratification
to get your satisfaction.
And you need to understand the nature of the
frustration that comes such that you can start
to manage your wants.
You need serious, full-on suffering to find
the answers to the questions of meaning that
we talked about.
You do.
My son needed a bootcamp.
You and I need substantial problems with mood,
to put it euphemistically.
No, look, we need sadness.
Jung, Freud's greatest student, Carl Jung,
so much greater in so many ways, said that
you don't really understand happiness until
you've experienced unhappiness because of
the contrast.
But more to the point, you've not been fully
alive because unhappiness is what actually
— the suffering is what helps you understand
what you're made of and what you can bear.
And only then will you find the answers to
the "Why am I alive?"
or "For what I'd be willing to die?"
questions.
You don't find the meaning questions, the
answers at that week at the beach in Ibiza.
You find it in the depths when somebody you
love dies, when you're afraid of what your
future holds, when you feel hopeless.
That's when those moments become real, and
that suffering turns out to be an integral
part in your journey to happiness.
So the number one thing that Oprah and I will
be very disappointed about is that people
don't actually become more fully alive through
the transcendent passage of both happierness
and the unhappiness that is a part of what
it means to be a real person.
Tim Ferriss: It is a diverse and ever-changing
tapestry, that is for sure.
Arthur Brooks: It is.
And I think about it, one of the biggest mistakes
that I think that my students make — by
the way, right now, if I were to go back to
1968 or 1969 Woodstock and the hippies said,
"If it feels good, do it."
I remember my dad heard that for the first
time, and he's like, "That's the end of America."
He was kind of right.
Anyway, if we had a Woodstock today, it might
be, "If it feels bad, make it stop.
If I'm suffering, treat it.
If there's pain, it's evidence that I'm defective,
that I'm broken.
Something's got to change."
That's wrong.
That's wrong thinking.
Look, the Tim Ferriss I'm talking to right
now had to suffer.
I mean, these messages that you're giving
are dramatically different than what you were
writing 15 and 20 years ago.
They're dramatically different.
It doesn't mean it was wrong 15 and 20 years
ago, but it was incomplete.
It wasn't deep in the same way.
And the depth actually comes from the — not
just from the good.
It also comes from the bad.
Andrew Solomon, who wrote The Noonday Demon,
have you read that book?
Tim Ferriss: No.
Arthur Brooks: It's the best book I've ever
read about anxiety and depression.
Andrew Solomon's a phenomenal writer.
Tim Ferriss: All right, so what is the title
again?
Arthur Brooks: The Noonday Demon, which was
an ancient way of talking about depression,
which comes over you like a noonday demon.
Tim Ferriss: It's like the black dog.
Arthur Brooks: It's like Winston Churchill's
black dog for sure.
The Noonday Demon, in the end, it's an incredible
book.
It's a total page-turner for anybody who's
actually had anything close to —
Tim Ferriss: At face value, does not sound
like a page-turner.
Arthur Brooks: I know.
It's phenomenal, though.
It's so interesting.
It's just beautiful writing.
But in the end, he said, "In the sum and final
balance, I have to conclude that I love my
depression because it's part of who I am as
a person, and it's allowed me to learn what
my life is all about.
I don't wish it on anybody.
I don't want it to come back, but it is who
I am, and so therefore, I have no choice but
to love it."
I'm paraphrasing, but his words are more beautiful
than anything I could remember.
But it's really an important thing for us
to remember.
And anybody who's watching you and who follows
you and who admires you and gets a lot of
sustenance from the knowledge that you bring
to this podcast, what they have to realize
is that they are beneficiaries of Tim Ferriss's
suffering.
And if they want to lift up the world, they
have to suffer too.
Tim Ferriss: It's food for thought.
Yep.
Food for thought.
May not be candy bars, might be high fiber,
but it is important food for thought.
Arthur Brooks: It's a philosophical Clif bar.
Sorry, people love those.
Not to cast aspersions, my friends at Clif
—
Tim Ferriss: But I have thought about this
very deliberately, and I don't wish suffering
upon anyone, but I had someone give me very
good advice at one point, and the words can
be substituted, of course.
But she said to me after I'd gone through
— very gifted therapist with a lot of experience,
a lot of mileage with different types of patients,
including some very tragic and difficult cases.
And she said, "Take your pain, make it part
of your medicine."
And I was like, "Okay," meaning the medicine
in my case, the way I think of that is what
I can teach or provide or just the perspective
through which I can speak and explore, given
that I have the history that I have and understand.
Arthur Brooks: This is what the best therapists
do.
They teach you about yourself.
They help you to learn and grow from your
pain, and they help you to treat yourself
and serve others.
That's what the great therapists do.
The worst therapist is like, "Yeah, I'll help
you take care of that.
We'll make that problem go away."
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I want to learn.
I want to grow and I want to surf.
Yeah.
Surf part has been very critical to the tether
of meaning that has given the suffering meaning.
Tim Ferriss: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Meaning made it — I don't say
irrelevant, but the greater the potency of
the meaning, the less the suffering incapacitates
you.
Let me ask you, is it possible you're not
afraid to suffer more now?
Arthur Brooks: Because you said pleasure and
as a defense, et cetera, et cetera.
But I don't feel like I'm sitting with somebody
who's afraid of suffering.
Tim Ferriss: It's certainly less than it was.
I also think that they're just pleasurable
things that I really like.
Arthur Brooks: Well, there's that.
Tim Ferriss: There's that.
Weird, how bizarre.
There is that —
Arthur Brooks: So I remember reading about
one of your sexual experiences in The 4-Hour
Body where it was like, "To get more testosterone,
and then I ate a single Brazil nut."
And you're —
Tim Ferriss: Oh.
Yeah, it was lots of Brazil nuts, cholesterol
loading.
I did lots of crazy stuff in The 4-Hour Body.
Arthur Brooks: But it was somebody who knew
how to have fun.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah, that chapter.
Arthur Brooks: How old were you?
What, 34 or something when you —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, early thirties.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
So anyway, no, I respect the fact that you
like to have fun and you like to feel good.
I get that, but I don't sense fear from you.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
I would also say what I have done is I've
built into my life a lot of premeditated,
deliberate discomfort to inoculate myself
against the fear of unpredictable discomfort.
And it's not a cure-all, but I have found
that —
Arthur Brooks: It's exposure therapy.
Tim Ferriss: It's exposure therapy, also just
wadding into some of the deep waters psychologically
and psycho-emotionally that I would be prone
to fearing.
Learning how to take swimming lessons in some
of those deep waters, I would say is also
an approach.
So, it resembles exposure therapy, but there's
also a skill development piece on top of that,
which is combined with the exposure I would
say, which I know is a bit nebulous.
Arthur Brooks: No, no, but it makes perfect
sense and there's actually a way that we can
all get better at that, because I know a lot
of people are watching this like, "Yeah.
How do we get better at that?"
Here's one way to do that that actually is
a very practical way to do it, start each
day with a statement of fact and then an aspiration.
The statement of fact is, "I don't know what's
going to happen this day.
I don't know."
I learned this from a pediatric oncologist,
by the way, somebody who gives bad cancer
diagnoses to kids.
He says he tells the parents to every day
start the day saying, "I don't know what's
going to happen in my future, but I do know
I am alive this day and I'm deeply grateful
for everything that happens for good and for
bad."
It takes cojones, man.
It's hard because you're like, you catch your
breath a little bit.
Because what Mother Nature wants you to do
is to look for the good feelings and to avoid
the bad feelings, because that's the evolutionary
imperative, to avoid the disgust and the anger
and the sadness and the grief and the loneliness,
and to avoid those things, not to embrace
those things to say it's inevitable, bring
it on.
But if you can actually do that to steal yourself,
to steal — as they say in Isaiah, "I steel
my face like flint."
And that's how to do it.
"Look, I don't know what's going to happen
today, but I do want to know I'm alive right
now.
I'm not going to waste this day.
And the way I don't waste this day is by being
grateful for every single thing that happens,
good and bad.
Bring it on.
Here we go."
Tim Ferriss: It's a gift I received quite
a while ago, but actually — steel my face
like flint.
It is a piece of, I think it is steel, and
it's engraved with a quote from, I think it
is Neale Donald Walsch.
I may be getting that off.
Someone can fact check.
But the quote is, "The struggle ends when
the gratitude begins."
And it's such good advice.
Yeah.
And you don't have to be grateful only for
the obviously good things.
Arthur Brooks: No, no, no, no.
On the contrary.
And that's really, that's what separates first-course
gratitude from PhD-level stuff is saying — and
by the way, here's a practical way to do that,
to be grateful for bad things, a very practical
way to do it.
I ask my students to make a failure journal.
And so what that is that every time bad thing
happens, something bad happens frequently.
When you're 28 years old, somebody breaks
your heart today and tomorrow you’re going
to be on a test.
And the next day after that, you don't get
the interview for that job you hoped for.
And it's just a constant string of disappointments
and thrills because it's like when you're
28 years old.
So, every time something happens that really
frustrates and disappoints you or you screw
up or whatever, you take out your failure
journal and you write in your failure journal
what happened.
And then you leave two lines open behind it,
and you put reminders on your phone, ding,
one month from now you've got to go back and
six months from now.
One month from now, you've got to go back
and say what you learned from that thing that
you would forget otherwise.
And six months from now, you've got to go
back and say a good thing that happened because
of that thing.
And there's always entries, always, always,
always.
And so it's like, "I went into my performance
review and I thought I was doing a really
good job.
My boss basically told me that I'm a B player
at best."
This happens constantly.
"That bums me out and I just want to put it
behind me, and I want to go hang out with
my friends and have a couple of beers and
complain about my boss and move on."
No, no, no, no.
Write it on your failure journal one month
from now, remember it and go back.
"Huh?
You know what I learned from that is I thought
I was going to be super bummed about that
for a long time, and it bothered me for a
week."
That's interesting.
Now that's homeostasis.
There's a lot of brain science in that.
Six months later, you come back and you say,
"When I thought about that, I realized that
that probably wasn't the perfect fit for my
career.
And I went on the market and I have a better
job now.
I think that the job I have now is a better
fit."
And every single thing that happens that you
put into your failure journal, you will realize
that there's something generative that happens
from this in terms of learning and in terms
of gratitude.
And you will turn that thing into something
— sooner or later when something really
bad happens to you, you're going to be like,
"Oh, God, I get to put it in the failure journal."
It'll really change your perspective on it,
because failure and disappointment and frustration
and sacrifice and pain will take on their
proper perspective, which is part of your
full life.
Tim Ferriss: We shall see.
That's great.
We shall see.
That's terrible.
Arthur Brooks: I know.
The famous parallel.
Tim Ferriss: We shall see.
Arthur Brooks: We shall see that famous parallel.
So true.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Well, Arthur, this has been so
much fun.
Now, the title of the book is —
Arthur Brooks: Build the Life You Want: The
Art and Science of Getting Happier.
Tim Ferriss: And by the time this comes up,
people will be able to certainly find it and
purchase it.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, yeah.
"Where all fine books are sold" is the saying.
Tim Ferriss: Where all fine books —
Arthur Brooks: And also, if people like, Oprah
and I will read it to you.
Tim Ferriss: You mean, I'm guessing, in audiobook
form, not on Cameo.
Arthur Brooks: Look, no, we'll come to your
house and with dulcet tones of Oprah's voice,
we'll lull you to sleep now.
No, I mean, we read it.
Tim Ferriss: You could raise a lot of money
that way.
Arthur Brooks: Yeah, that's right.
"Sorry, Oprah, I committed us to a thing.
Let's just say the book tour is taking on
new dimensions."
But we read the book for Penguin Random House,
and I'm really super happy with the way that
it turned out, mostly because my voice is
interspersed with her beautiful voice, one
of the most famous voices in America.
Tim Ferriss: What an incredible experience.
Congratulations.
Arthur Brooks: Thank you.
Tim Ferriss: So people can find the book where
all fine books are sold.
I just love saying that.
And is there anything else you'd like to point
people to, whether it's a social profile or
a request of the audience, an ask of the audience,
something you'd like to close with, anything
at all that you'd like to add before we wind
to a close?
Arthur Brooks: This is really a teaching experience,
both for me and Oprah and just part of my
life, which is dedicated to writing, speaking,
and teaching about love and happiness, to
bring people together in bonds of love, using
the science and ideas.
That's really my mission statement for the
rest of my life.
And that really is a teaching mission, just
like yours is a teaching mission.
So there's a lot of stuff that I'm doing ancillary
to books and columns, et cetera.
I have classes like video classes and things
that people can watch.
And my goal in doing those things — this
all on my website, arthurbrooks.com, but when
people do those things, my goal is training
them to be happiness teachers.
This is really what it's all about because
remember, it's understand, change your habits,
share with others.
And so to learn more about exactly how to
do that, we're developing a lot of resources
that make that possible in, I think, a pretty
effective way.
And I would love people to do that for the
single reason that I want a movement.
I want to be part of a movement of people
whose hobby is the science of happiness and
bringing it to others.
There's a lot of people who are broken in
this world and who are sad and who are suffering.
And if we had people who are warriors for
greater happiness for themselves through others,
through real knowledge and a commitment to
change, I'm truly convinced that this is the
one thing that I can do that could have an
impact on the world that needs to be a lot
happier.
Tim Ferriss: Arthur, so glad that we were
able to find the time, have this conversation,
and I admire the work you do.
I respect the work you do.
I value the work that you put out in the world.
It does help people.
So I wanted to also just simply thank you
for putting out what you put out and spending
time on the things you spend time on.
Arthur Brooks: Likewise, Tim.
I've only met you today in person, but I feel
like I've known you for a long time because
I've been consuming your work like so many
millions of other people, and you've enriched
my life a lot.
Thank you for that.
Tim Ferriss: Thanks, man.
I really appreciate it.
This has really sparked a lot in me.
I've taken copious notes, so I have a number
of things that I'll be focusing on: getting
small, Brothers K, muscular philosophies,
I just love the phrasing, so I wrote it down,
Aristotle, Aquinas, all things that can lead
you to build the life that you want.
And for everybody listening, we'll have extensive
show notes, links to everything as usual at
tim.blog/podcast.
And until next time, be just a bit kinder
than is necessary to others and to yourself,
and thanks for tuning in.